Dann fangen wir doch an, oder?
Ja, hallo und willkommen zu Mobile Max Ausgaben Nummer 21. Und wir müssen uns gleich zu Beginn bekannt geben.
Steve ist krank.
Steve ist krank und Denis krank auch schon zu schwächeln.
Und mein MacBook geht es auch schon schlechter.
Ja, und dein MacBook ist auch irgendwie alles. Was ist da bei deinem MacBook?
Das hat hier eine rote Linie auf dem Bildschirm, das ist eine senkrechte.
So von oben nach unten?
So von oben nach unten. Und das werden langsam mehr. Also das sind jetzt so zwei Pixel, knallrot, 100 Prozent.
Vielleicht ist es eine Hormonstörung.
Weißt du, dass er seine Nahrung nicht mehr so richtig aufnehmen kann?
Ja, also er kann einfach die Datennahrung, die von dem Rechner kommt, kann das Display nicht mehr so verarbeiten. Und das baut halt ab.
Die kommt nicht mehr durch das Kabel durch.
Vielleicht solltest du eine 6-monatige Pause einleiten. Einfach mal bis Juni von der Bildfläche komplett verschwenden. Tja, also, Denis ist nicht da. Wir wissen nicht, warum er ist weg. Wir haben ihn angerufen. Er ist irgendwie offline. Keine Ahnung, was los ist. Wie auch immer. Das wollen wir jetzt auch gar nicht weiter erörtern. Wir müssen damit leben. Das macht es jetzt allerdings schwierig, auf den Shitload an Feedback einzugehen, der hier seit der letzten Sendung aufgeschlagen ist, aufgrund unserer Drobo- und insbesondere der ZFS-Diskussion.
Und da ich zum Thema ZFS in wesentlichem weiß, dass es eine Abkürzung ist, die für irgendwas steht.
Ja, und das ist jetzt auch so viel Shit, dass ich das einfach überhaupt nicht zusammengefasst bekomme, weil da muss man sich lange durchlesen. Ich werd mal Folgendes sagen. Also erstens, mein Drobo hat jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen nicht mehr rumgezickt. Ich hab ihn halt neu aufgesetzt, das war ja auch letztes Mal schon der Fall. Und betreibe den jetzt mehr oder weniger erfolgreich in dieser doppel 2 GB Konfiguration an meiner Time Capsule. Und ich kann jetzt sozusagen auch das, was ich eigentlich tun wollte, den Inhalt der internen Festplatte auf die externe Festplatte, sprich den Drobo, kopieren und hab dann sozusagen einen Secondary Backup, also ein Backup von Backup, was an sich erstmal eine tolle Idee ist. Und hab halt auch so ein Device zum Auslagern. Das ist eigentlich alles das, was ich wollte. Das performt natürlich nicht jetzt besonders, aber ist jetzt auch nicht das Wichtigste. Wichtigste ist, es läuft. Ja, es gab extrem viel Feedback. Also ich will es jetzt auch nicht komplett unerwähnt lassen. Es ging in verschiedene Richtungen. Erstmal wurde das generell alles sehr interessant gefunden. Es wurde auf verschiedene NAS-Projekte verwiesen. frinas.org, das zeig ich mir jetzt noch nicht weiter angeschaut.
Ganz kurz zwischendurch, man merkt daran, dass man alt wird im digitalen Zeitalter, wenn man die aktuellen......TLAs nicht mehr kennt... .dass man die aktuellen Einheiten für Speicherkapazitäten nicht mehr kennt, sondern immer das Letzte sagt, zum Beispiel Gigabyte statt Terra.
Was hab ich jetzt gerade gesagt?
2 Giga.
Hab ich schon wieder gesagt? Oh man, ich werd alt.
Ich bin immer noch beim Mega insofern.
Okay, ja, Terra Bytes, mein Gott. Auf jeden Fall gab's verschiedene Leute, und deswegen hab ich das auch noch mal explizit geblockt, die halt da geäußert haben, dass sie ja das eine ganz tolle Idee finden würden, das Ganze mit ZFS aufzusetzen. Es gab viele kluge Hinweise in Bezug auf Mirroring, wie man irgendwie Rates vergrößern kann und so weiter. Und eigentlich wollte ich das dem Denis heute alles unter die Nase reiben, aber jetzt ist halt Denis nicht da. Und deswegen können wir dieses Thema eigentlich nur vertagen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Ja, das wäre ich sehr dafür, weil ich hab wirklich von ZFS exakt null Ahnung.
Du hast...
Mehr als null Ahnung.
Mehr als null, aber weniger als Denis und...
Definitiv weniger als Denis, weil Denis hat das immerhin schon aktiv im Betrieb. Und ich lese mir die ganze Zeit nur die Datasheets durch und find's toll. Und von daher, ja. Allerdings gab's interessantes Feedback. Es gab zum Beispiel ein Open Solaris-Podcast, die wohl hier auch mal reingehört haben und ganz überrascht waren, dass wir uns da so positiv über andere Betriebssysteme geäußert haben. Weil wir sind ja Mac-User, verstehst du? Und Mac-User finden alles andere einfach doof. Ja, bzw. ignorieren es einfach. Dem ist nicht so. Das kann ich nur noch mal bestätigen. Wir sind hier sehr aufgeschlossen. Und vor allem, Apple schubsen macht Spaß. Und deswegen habe ich auch noch mal auf dieses Timeslider-Feature hingewiesen. Ich weiß nicht, hast du den Hinweis verfolgen können?
Den habe ich. Ich habe es mir mal angeguckt, die Seite dazu.
Hast du diesen Screencast gesehen?
Ich habe nur einen Screenshot gesehen von so einem User-Interface, wo man dann so einen kleinen Regler hat, den man einstellen kann.
Das gibt es nämlich auch noch in Bewegt. Und der Screencast zeigt halt im Wesentlichen, wie man das bedient. Und kurz gesagt, es ist eigentlich vollkommen naheliegend. Also er hat so eine Demo gemacht, macht da so ein Open Office, wie heißt ja nochmal gleich, das Sliderzeugungstool, wie auch immer, macht da so eine Präsentation, ändert da so ein paar Sachen, hat in seinem Finder, welcher da heißt Naughty Loss, in dem Knobbasiertes System, hat er dann halt auch so ein Preview von dem ersten Slide, wo man halt sieht, was da drauf steht. Und dann ändert er so ein paar Sachen und speichert es nochmal ab. Und das System war jetzt so eingestellt, dass es alle 15 Minuten einen Snapshot macht. Und dann hatte er in diesem Fenster für dieses Verzeichnis so ein Slider halt, so ein Timeslider.
Der Schieberegler?
Ja, mit dem er halt einfach in die Vergangenheit gehen konnte. Also so wie Apple das macht mit diesem bekloppten Star Wars, schieß mich tot irgendwie, jetzt auch Windows XP Optik auf Mac OS X. Ich meine mal ehrlich, diese Time Machine Optik, Max, ist schon grenzwertig, sag ich mal. Ja, also da müsste doch auch wirklich der gepflegte Fanboy Probleme haben. Als ich das in der Beta gesehen habe, dachte ich mir so, ha ha ha, wie lustig, das schafft es nie ins Release. Ja, weil ich dachte, das wäre jetzt mal so ein Demo. Ich dachte, das ist ein Easter Egg, die können auch nicht ernsthaft mir jetzt mit animierten Sternenhaufen irgendwie ankommen, so ein Fasta zu machen und ich meine mal, ehrlich, hast du es mal benutzt? Es ist zum Kotzen. Es ist langweilig, ja langweilig ist es auch, es ist langsam, es trägt meiner Auffassung nach einfach überhaupt nicht dazu bei, mehr zu begreifen, was Sache ist. Ganz im Gegenteil, du hast so einen Ordner, im Finder, da drückst du diese Tasse jetzt irgendwie, Time Machine, dann verschwindet alles, was du gerade so in deinem, worauf du dich gerade konzentrierst.
Außer das Fenster.
Ja, das verschwindet, das heißt, du bist aktiv damit beschäftigt, zu begreifen, was jetzt irgendwie überhaupt passiert, weil dein eigenes Fenster ja auch nicht so bleibt, wie es ist, sondern es resize sich und so weiter.
Wenn es richtig schon in die Mitte reinpasst.
Und noch schlimmer, wenn du diesen Ordner, auf den du gerade blickst, noch gar nicht in deinem Backup hast, dann springt er dann glaube ich sogar raus und so. Also es ist, keine Ahnung, es ist furchtbar.
Also furchtbar würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil ich würde ein paar gute Haare dran lassen. Also es ist ja mit 10,5 gekommen und das war die erste Version, die hatte noch ihre Ösen und Haken. Also was ich ja, es ist eine Lösung, die theoretisch in jedem Programm funktioniert. Also die funktioniert ja auch in Mails, die funktioniert ja auch im Adressbuch.
Ja, sehr theoretisch, weil praktisch hat sich da wenig getan. Ich meine, kennst du ein einziges Programm, außer denen, die serienmäßig dabei sind, die davon Gebrauch machen? Ich kenne nichts. Kein einziges Mac-Tool hat Time Machine implementiert.
Ist das noch zu schwer einfach oder wieso nicht?
Na offensichtlich ist es nicht einfach genug, weil sonst sehe ich...
Kommt sonst eine LCD, ja klar.
Ja, also ich meine, das ist eigentlich eine totale Niederlage. Damit habe ich auch nicht gerechnet. Ich dachte, da könnten jetzt eine Menge Programme bei ihr... Ja, und ich finde, an der Stelle ist das Time Machine Konzept von Apple auch wirklich gescheitert. Also, wenn sie es jetzt in einem anderen Jahr nicht schaffen, da mindestens auch einen einzigen Shareware-Autor mal auf ihre Seite zu ziehen, dann ist da einfach was geklappt.
Das müssen sie besser machen. Aber eigentlich ist das Konzept nicht...
Ich dachte, ja, klar ist es eigentlich. Eigentlich war auch Power Talk, was sie mal rausgebracht haben, war eigentlich auch mal eine tolle Idee.
Und OpenDoc war...
Power Talk war so mit, ich schiebe dir mal eine Datei auf dein User-Icon und dann geht das übers Netz und dann ist das bei dir in der Inbox auf deinem Desktop. System 7 Pro.
Das konnte ich nie nutzen, weil ich keine vernetzten Macs hatte.
Ja genau, aber das war an sich auch so eine tolle Idee, aber das waren einfach so komplizierte APIs und irgendwie dann haben sie auch noch diesen Schwachsinn eingeführt, mit wir haben jetzt eine Pro-Version von unserem Betriebssystem, für die manche Leute bezahlen und nicht. Also eine bessere Methode, Developer auszuschließen oder User-Acceptance niedrig zu halten, konnten sie sich fast gar nicht einfallen.
Ja, das waren ja auch die schlimmen Jahre.
Das waren die schlimmen Jahre und das war dann auch wirklich fast der Anfang vom Ende. So, aber offensichtlich sind sie davor nicht gefeiert. Und dieses Time Machine User Interface, ich sag's nochmal, das ist einfach Distracting. Was bitte hat das mit meinem Computing zu tun? Ich will nicht, dass mir so eine Software, nur weil ich mal eben in einen Backup schaue. Ich meine, die inszenieren das, als wäre das jetzt irgendwie der Beginn eines Hollywood-Spielfilms.
Da kommt keine Musik.
Dein Backup, so. Dann geht das irgendwie über so Time-Capsule, ja, ist schnarchend langsam, das heißt, es dauert dann irgendwie so 30 Sekunden, bis dann so, mmh.
Du traust das ja als Netzwerk.
Ja! Da kommt so ein Fenster nach dem anderen, da muss ich das auch noch wirklich abwarten, bis er dann wirklich rausgefunden hat, wie viele Backup-Versionen es davon gibt. So, mmh, eins nach dem anderen, mmh, mmh, mmh. Und du sitzt da vorne so, ich will nur mal kurz schauen, ob es da irgendwas gibt, so, mmh, mmh.
Also mit einer USB-Platte geht das relativ okay.
Ja, aber das kann ja wohl nicht deren Ernst sein, dass das so scheiße skaliert. Ich meine, dann ist mal irgendwas langsam und dann krieg ich das auch gleich im User-Interface. Mal ehrlich, ich meine, ich will 30 Frames pro Sekunde in meinem Betriebssystem haben und zwar immer. Und nicht so ein Kack. Ich meine, wenn ich ein ruckelndes OS haben will, dann hole ich mir Windows.
Also ich will jetzt, seit wann, seit wann, seit wann bin ich hier der Apple-Verteidiger? Seit wann sagst du was pro Windows?
Du bist jetzt der Einzige, der hier sitzt.
Ja, Mist, ja, nee, also ich, ich hab schon häufiger was pro Windows gesagt.
Was glaubst du, wie ich geguckt habe, als ich seinerzeit mal so ein Windows NT irgendwie auf meinem Tisch stehen hatte?
Ach so, Mac OS 7 Zeiten.
Ja, so und daneben hatte ich irgendwie so mein Mac OS 7 5 Release V2-Schnickes gedönst, ja und jedes bekloppte Netscape-Release crashte diese Kiste und nahm alles irgendwie mit sich mit. Das ging nicht, verstehst du? Das ging einfach nicht. Das war einfach so offensichtlich, dass Apple komplett gerade ihre Sachen vor die Wand fährt, während Microsoft, ich meine, die haben dann vielleicht nicht alles begriffen, aber sie haben zumindest mal begriffen, dass so Speicherschutz auch eine tolle Idee ist und das gibt's halt, da gab's da halt auch schon seit 10, 15 Jahren. Das wäre doch mal vielleicht ganz cool, dass man das auch mal in so ein Desktop-OS einbaut.
Und so präemptives Multitasking.
Gut, ich meine, da haben sie dann halt auch gelernt, dann haben sie halt gesehen, ok, alles klar, unser OS taucht nichts, was machen wir damit? Wir schmeißen es weg und haben es einfach durch was Besseres ersetzt, dass das eben auch schon konnte, nämlich ich hole nichts. Und dann war ich auch wieder glücklich. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass ich alles hinkriege.
Nein, nein, ok, also Time Machine ist... Also es ist nicht furchtbar. Das erste Mal hat man überhaupt...
Du bist ein Fanboy.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Natürlich, ich bin Fanboy, aber ich mache überhaupt das erste Mal in meinem Leben überhaupt Backups. Hast du vorher Backups gemacht?
Nein.
Siehste, wir machen Backups. Also das ist der absolute Minimal-Konsens.
Ich rede jetzt auch nur von Time Machine dem User-Interface. Ich rede jetzt nicht von Time Machine die Funktionalität. Darüber habe ich ja schon sehr viel Gutes gesagt.
Time Machine, das Datalsystem, ist glaube ich auch komplett Gülle und so. Und dieses... Also ich meine, das könnte man alles besser machen.
Das ist das, was wir letztes Mal rausgefunden haben. Genau, es gibt drei Aspekte. Es gibt die grundsätzliche Idee von Time Machine ist prima. So und es ist gut, dass es das gibt. Und Leute haben jetzt Backups. Das hat mir schon eine Menge Daten gerettet und bestimmt vielen anderen Leuten auch. Dann gibt es ein Time Machine und seine konkrete Implementierung in der Realität, dass wir immer noch HFS plus haben. Da ist einfach die Tatsache, dass HFS plus einfach uralt ist, macht die Sache madig. Weil du kannst keine Snapshots machen, was für so ein Backup einfach mal eigentlich eine Voraussetzung ist, damit du einfach mal so einen Cut hast. Ich meine, was ist, wenn ihr wenn jetzt hier mein Time Machine einkickt und ein Backup startet, dann guckt es am R als erstes Mal, was hat sich geändert. Okay, das geht vergleichsweise schnell dadurch, dass sie halt diese Fallsystem-Events aussetzen.
Das heißt, es gibt jetzt... Naja, nur wenn du nicht zu lange zwischendurch keinen Backup gemacht hast. Also wenn du zu lange Zeit...
Ich sage nur, es geht vergleichsweise schnell, weil ich hatte mal eine R-Sync-basierte Lösung, die sozusagen wirklich mit einem Skript durch jedes Verzeichnis durchgegangen ist und geguckt hat, hat sich was verändert.
Das dauert ewig.
Das dauert ewig. Ich wollte alle 24 Stunden Backup machen und allein das überprüfen, was sich geändert hat, dauerte 28 Stunden. Also ich meine, auf der Basis kann man wirklich keinen Backup machen. Weil halt einfach die Platte zu groß und der Rechner zu langsam war oder die Platte zu langsam war, weiß ich, auf jeden Fall ging das nicht. Mit diesen Fallsystem-Events, wo sie ja permanent in ein Log-File von einem Volumen reinschreiben, wann sich welches Direktory geändert hat, ist Time Machine in der Lage, relativ zügig zu sagen, okay, es gab Änderungen hier und da. Aber dann dauert das ändern. Sagen wir mal, es haben sich jetzt 30 Gigabyte Daten geändert. Das passiert bei mir mal, ob es zum Beispiel eine Sendung aufnimmt, dann kopiere ich irgendwie die Audio-Dateien 20 mal hin und her. Genau. Vielleicht sind es auch weniger, keine Ahnung, oder man war mal eine Woche weg, hat sich viel geändert und so weiter. Dann dauert also allein das sichern der Daten ein paar Stunden.
Der schaltet ja auch auf eine niedrige Priorität, wenn du im Hintergrund bist.
Genau, und dann arbeitest du halt eine Stunde.
Was hat dein Backup?
Genau, das ist nämlich genau die Frage. Was backupt er eigentlich? Was sagt mir diese Uhrzeit, wann er was gebackupt hat? Heißt das, dass das die letzte Zeit ist?
Noch wesentlich problematischer finde ich ja da irgendwelche SQLite-Datenbanken oder sowas, von denen es ja nun auch Mac OS mittlerweile mehr als genug gibt, die man ja eigentlich schließen muss, bevor man sie backupt.
Das ist aber noch mal ein ganz anderes Problem und das hast du auch mit ZFS.
Inkonsistente Daten.
Genau, jetzt wollte ich noch kurz sagen, also Snapshots haben gegenüber dem Problem, was ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe, was macht er sozusagen in dieser Stunde, während er ein Backup macht?
Das gibt es die Stunde nicht.
Genau, das gibt es die Stunde nicht. Das heißt, dann hast du wirklich einen Cut in dem Moment, wo das Snapshot erfolgt ist, ist wirklich exakt ab dieser Sekunde, alles was sich dann ändert, kommt nicht mehr in dieses Backup. Weil das ist ein atomarer Schritt, also zumindest bei ZFS ist das so. Sollte eigentlich jedes Snapshot so sein, aber ich kenne jetzt die konkrete Implementierung anderer Snapshots-Systeme jetzt, auf anderen Fallsystemen so nicht, aber im Prinzip ist die Idee immer die gleiche. Du hast halt eine Directory-Struktur, du machst den Snapshot, du erhältst dir diese Directory-Struktur und danach, wenn weitere Änderungen auf das Dateisystem kommen, dann machst du so eine Copy-and-Write-Geschichte. Du kopierst die Datenstruktur in dem Moment, wo sie sich ändert und hast sozusagen eine vollständige Kopie. Die verweisen dann sozusagen auf separate Datenblöcke dann, die neue Version auf die neuen und so weiter. Die sind dann beide vorhanden, das heißt, dein Plattenbedarf wächst eben auch nur so weit an, wie du wirklich reale Änderungen hast und das eben auf Block-Ebene, nicht auf Dateiebene.
Das können ja virtuelle Maschinen auch schon eine ganze Weile, so VM-Ware oder so was haben ja auch diese Funktion, dass du zu jedem Zeitpunkt einen Snapshot machen kannst, vom gesamten Betriebssystem und exakt da weitermachst, wo du aufgehört hast.
Ja gut, aber die schreiben dann aber auch wahrscheinlich eine vollständige Kopie des Speichers weg.
Das Arbeitsspeicher schon, aber ich meine, der virtuellen Festplatte, die sie haben, da gehen sie wahrscheinlich genauso vor. Sie haben ja auch eine virtuelle Festplatten-Datei und über das schreiben sie dann einfach die Änderungen nicht.
Ah, ok, darüber habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken gemacht. Zurück nochmal zu Time Machine. Also wir haben jetzt sozusagen diese verschiedenen Aspekte. Und dann gibt es einfach das User Interface. Und jetzt komme ich wieder zurück auf Timeslider und wie ich der Meinung bin, wie das integriert sein sollte. Was mich von Anfang an gestört hat bei Time Machine und diesem User Interface ist, dass sie das behandeln, als wäre das was total anderes. Das ist so dieses, tada, jetzt schaust du in dein Backup. Alles andere hat zu enden. Du darfst jetzt nicht twittern, du darfst jetzt nicht irgendwie deine Notizen machen in deinem Notepad, was du gerade offen hast.
Je länger ich darüber nachdenke, desto... Also ich finde, ich meine diese 3D-Buttons, über deren Schönheits...
Damit wollen wir gar nicht erst anfangen.
Da brauchen wir nicht drüber zu diskutieren. Ich finde es aber insofern jetzt gar nicht so verkehrt, weil es ist ja so, man zieht ja tatsächlich die Daten drum herum, die Fenster, die ausgeblendet werden in dem Moment, also man nimmt ja nur dieses eine Fenster mit in die Vergangenheit, in Anführungsstrichen. Also ich meine, es geht ja...
Ja und warum soll ich mir nicht gleichzeitig zwei Fenster in der Vergangenheit anschauen? Warum soll ich mir nicht anschauen, da ist mein Archivordner und da ist mein aktueller Projekteordner und ich schau bei beiden mal nach, wie das vor zwei Wochen war. Was ist, wenn ich zwei Backups miteinander vergleichen will in meinem Finder? Dann geht das einfach nicht.
Das ist einfach ein Kinderinterface.
Das ist ein Kinderinterface. Das ist ein User-Interface, das ist Fischerpreis für irgendwie Datenrätten.
Das Prinzip ist doch, dass du immer nur ein Fenster mit in die Vergangenheit nimmst.
Ja, was soll das?
So ist das Konzept.
Ja, so ist das Konzept.
Das Konzept ist scheiße. Nee, ich will ja nie alles. Wenn ich zum Beispiel in meinem Adressbuch bin, feststelle ich, ich habe eine Mail gelöscht. Ein konkreter Fall, den ich schon hatte. Versehentlich, irgendwie vor drei Tagen war sie noch da, mal gucken, wo die Mail ist. Dann gehe ich in diesen Ordner rein und scrolle so lange zurück in diesen Fenster, bis ich genau meine Mail wieder sehe. Dann will ich ja gar nicht, dass ich die anderen Fenster ändere. Die sollen ja gefließt sein. Ich möchte ja nicht, dass mein PDF-Dokument oder das, woran ich gerade arbeite, das soll ja nicht mit in die Vergangenheit rutschen. Es soll ja genau diese eine Mail wieder haben. Dann ist es auch notwendig, dass ich das visuell dargestellt kriege. Ich würde es toll finden, wenn es da was Besseres gäbe. So inkonsequent finde ich das gar nicht.
Ich finde, bei Dateien könnte man auch noch einen anderen View anbieten. Da finde ich diese Timeslider-Geschichte viel eleganter.
Bei Dateien bin ich auch mit Time-Maschinen schon lange dazu übergegangen, direkt in das Backup reinzugehen, Ordner aufmachen, Datei rückholen, fertig.
Das ist auch ein bisschen inkonsistent. Wie bildest du ab, dass es diesen Ordner gar nicht gab damals? Du gehst in der Vergangenheit zurück und irgendwann gab es diesen Ordner nicht. Das bietet dir dieses User-Interface auch nicht. Wie auch immer. Ob der eine oder andere Ansatz angemessener ist, ich finde, weder sieht es gut aus, noch teilen es die Leute. Und es wird vor allem nicht angenommen von der Programmiergemeinde.
Das ist wirklich ein echt großes Problem. Das sollten sie eigentlich auf die Reihe kriegen. Das sollte ja wirklich für so ein Programm nicht mehr sein, als macht er noch mal die Datei im Hintergrund auf und wir blenden das Fenster erst ein, wenn er nach hinten scrollt. Das sollte ja eigentlich gehen.
Ich finde auf jeden Fall, dass mit diesen Snapshots das muss auf jeden Fall dringend kommen. Aber ich wiederhole mich. So, was haben wir denn noch? Also es gab ja eigentlich nicht viel. Also ich habe zumindest jetzt nicht sehr viel aus der Nachrichtenlage als relevant genommen. Ich meine, okay, wir haben jetzt hier den temporären Abgang von Herrn Jobs. Er ist wohl dann doch ein bisschen kranker oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ihm ist das irgendwie alles wahrscheinlich...
Kann man langsam mal sagen, dass ich die Vermutung habe, dass das nicht so temporär ist, wie...
Er das immer darstellen wollte?
Wie er das immer darstellen wollte. Ich glaube, der ist krank und der wird seine Zeit jetzt vermutlich außerhalb von irgendwelchen großen Technologiekonzernen verbringen.
Ach, ich glaube es nicht. Der kommt wieder. Ich halte den für ausreichend, unverwüstlich. Aber ich will jetzt auch nicht in so eine Steve Jobs-Hand...
Wobei ich mir auch vorstellen kann, dass er sowieso sich eher auf das iPhone konzentriert, auf sein neues Hobby und nicht so sehr auf den Mac.
Ja, oder was auch immer. Aber ich meine, er ist ja nicht tot. Ich meine, wenn er jetzt zu Hause sitzt und mal Ruhe hat...
Ja man, der braucht nach 30 Jahren Führung an so viele Konzernen auch mal ein bisschen Urlaub.
Ich glaube es auch.
Außerdem kann er darüber nachdenken. Wie er den Palm Pre findet.
Nicht wahr? Ich hab ja so eine grobe Ahnung, dass Grund seiner Erkrankung durchaus auch dieser Palm Pre sein könnte. Nach allem, was man so hört.
Das ist aber jetzt wirklich eine sehr arge Verschwörungstheorie.
Man erstmal lassen. Palm hat auf der CES was vorgestellt, wo man... Also Palm war ja tot. Die haben früher fast tot. Wir erinnern uns noch, die haben diese Palm Pilots gebaut, die wir alle geliebt haben, weil es damals nichts besseres gab. Und dann haben sie gedacht, hey, die lieben diese Palm Pilots, weil es die einzigen Geräte sind. Und dann hat Microsoft angefangen, ganz ähnliche Geräte zu bauen. Und irgendwann hat Palm dann festgestellt, Moment mal, was wir da bauen, ist totaler Scheiße. Und nicht mal ein Smartphone haben sie auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Hattest du ein Palm?
Ich hatte ein Palm 3. Als IBM Nachbau. Der hieß dann IBM WorkPad, glaube ich, oder irgendwie so was.
Ich erinnere mich, dunkel.
So ein ganz hässliches Teil. Also es war eigentlich nur ein Palm 3 in ein bisschen anderem Gehäuse. Der hat dann irgendwann meinen Geist aufgegeben und dann habe ich mir ein Henspring Visor gekauft.
Und Henspring waren die Leute, die Palm gemacht haben.
Genau, die haben eine eigene Firma gegründet, haben sich eine Lizenz für das Betriebssystem gekauft von Palm.
Mitgeben lassen sozusagen, genau.
Und haben plötzlich angefangen, relativ geile Geräte zu bauen. Wobei dieser Henspring Visor, der hatte was ganz furchtbares. Das war so ein Slot, wo man theoretisch Erweiterungskarten hätte reinstecken können. Was aber, ich glaube, da hat nie wirklich jemand was für produziert.
Es gab dann glaube ich so WLAN-Karten und Telefonie-Geschichten.
Dann habe ich den irgendwann mal, der war in so einem wunderschönen Leder-Advie, was ich mal so in der Hand hielt und dann habe ich das mal so mit so einer großen Handbewegung durch den Raum geschleudert und der Visor flog dabei in hohen Bogen durch die Gegend und hat den Flug sehr gut überlebt, aber das aufkommt nicht, woraufhin ich mir dann ein Henspring Visor Deluxe gekauft habe. Und das waren, kennst du die Dinger noch? Das waren so super dünne?
Ich habe nie ein Henspring Gerät jemals gesehen, muss ich sagen.
Die waren echt sexy.
Habst du die in Deutschland?
Jaja klar, ich habe die ja in Deutschland gekauft. Die gab es sogar eine Zeit lang. Also den Visor Deluxe, den gab es damals so irgendwie relativ günstig sogar. Irgendwie bei Mediamarkt im Sonderangebot. Und ich habe natürlich, also meiner ist zwei Wochen später kaputt gegangen, sodass ich ihn mir bei Ebay holen musste. Aber das war so ein kleines silbernes Gerät, das war so dünn, dass dieser Stylus nicht mehr ins Gerät reinpasste, sondern er wurde so von außen draufgesteckt. Der Stylus. Und so ein gut fehlender Klappmechanismus oben für den Deckel, das war echt ein extrem schönes Gerät, sehr flach. Ich würde so schätzen so 5 mm vielleicht.
Na gut, aber wir wollen ja auf die aktuelle Geschichte kommen. Ich hatte so einen Pile, den allerersten, glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, ob es der allererste war oder der schon irgendwie mehr RAM hatte, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, ich hatte einen Pile Pilot Professional. Das war dann, glaube ich, 1997, wie so ein weiteres Modell.
Das dürfte die zweite Generation gewesen sein. Weißt du, was ich an den Piles immer ganz witzig fand?
Ich fand aber die Geldausgabe danach komplett sinnfrei. Das hätte ich mir echt sparen können.
Ich hab den geliebt.
Wofür? Was hast du damit gemacht?
Was ich gemacht habe, war damals massenhaft Zeitschriften gelesen. Ich bin damals sehr viel Bahn gefahren.
Du hast den als E-Book benutzt.
Ich hab den als E-Book-Reader genutzt. Ich hatte da so ein Programm, das hieß Plaka. Da konnte man Webseiten angeben. RSS-Feed gab es. Das war vor der Erfindung des RSS-Feeds. Das konnte aus Webseiten die wesentlichen Inhalte rauslegen. Gab es für Spiegel online alle Skripte. Dann wurden die abgesucht und runtergeladen aufs Gerät. Das war ein komplett automatisierter Prozess. Der funktionierte ziemlich gut. Und dann hat man die drauf gehabt auf seinem Palm. Dafür war es schon mal ein Lion Doll. Dann gab es ein fantastisches Spiel, das ich bis heute fürs iPhone noch nicht entdeckt hab. Vielleicht hat das ja jemand. Das heißt Traffic. Das war 3 Kilobyte groß. Das war wirklich lächerlich klein. Das war so ein Spiel, wo man... Man hatte so ein Auto, das dargestellt wurde, durch ein Rechteck. Das musste man durch das Umparken von anderen Autos, auch Rechtecke, aus einer Bucht rausbringen. Das war absolut süchtig machen, das Spiel. Wie heißt das?
Traffic.
Das gab es irgendwie als Brettspiel quasi. Dann haben das die Leute... Dann konnte man sich das... Das gab es auch für den Palm. Das war wieder für gemacht. Fürs iPhone wäre es noch besser. Das könnte man schön mit den Fingern bedienen. Das kann ruhig und einfach sein. Ich hab das so schön nie wiedergefunden. Für den Mac gibt es das Ganze. Da macht es nicht halb so viel Spaß. Man muss schnelle Bewegungen machen können. Und... Dann war es auch irgendwie mit Autobildchen und weißer Teufel was. Das war dann nicht mehr schnell.
Du machstest deinen Palm? Ich machte meinen Palm. Ich hatte eigentlich nichts gegen den Palm, aber ich hatte auch keine besonders gute Anwendung. Dafür. Das war halt so. Keine Ahnung. Irgendwie ist es schon so, dass man eigentlich, naja, wenn man viele Termine hatte, also das Ding war ja eigentlich auch im Business ein Erfolg.
Klar.
Und ich war einfach nicht im Business.
Im Business war ich auch nicht.
Und deswegen war das für mich auch nichts. Ansonsten hatte man eigentlich eher den Bedarf, ein Telefon zu haben. Wie auch immer. Ich machte auch das mit dem Stift irgendwie nicht, dass dieses Graffiti, naja, damit kann man zwar was eingeben, aber eigentlich ist das alles Quak-Wesen. Wie auch immer. Wir spulen mal vor.
Ein kleines Detail möchte ich noch erwähnen, weil man sich hardware-seitig mal ein bisschen mit dem Ding auseinandergesetzt hat. Oder von der Software. Da hat man festgestellt, die haben eigentlich nur den ersten Mac überhaupt genommen, den 128K beim Pilot, und haben den mit dem Hammer so lange draufgekloppt, bis der in der entsprechenden Größe war. Das war ein 68.000er Prozessor mit 128 KB RAM. Ich glaube, der Datum-Chip war der gleiche wie beim original Mac. Auf jeden Fall erkennt er auch diese 1. Januar 1904 Wars-Grenze. Die haben so etwas wie einen ResourceFork und einen DataFork in diesem PDB-Format, was sie hatten. Es gab Ressorts-Dateien, es gab die Dialog-Dateien, die hatten teilweise die Ressourcen. Früher beim klassischen Mac gab es so verschiedene Typen. Da waren dann innerhalb eines Programms ein Picked, das waren die Bilder, die da in dem Programm abgelegt waren. Die hatten eine bestimmte Endung. Die waren größtenteils identisch. Das müssen eh mal die Apple-Entwickler gewesen sein, die sich hingesetzt haben und das Ding einfach in klein nachproduziert haben. Das ging so weit, dass man sogar mit Sync Pascal, was damals, wenn man die entsprechenden Dateien ausgewechselt hat, konnte man mit einem 68.000er Mac-Compiler ein Programm bauen. Das war nichts, was Spaß gemacht hat, aber es ging theoretisch. Also die Liebe zu Apple oder die Bereitschaft, bei Apple abzukupfern, ist durchaus alt innerhalb der Firma.
Ja, da sind sie jetzt sozusagen auch beigeblieben und in ihrer hilflosen Situation. Ich meine, es war so, Palm hatte zuletzt angekündigt ein, wie sollte dieses Gerät noch gleich heißen?
Meinst du diesen Companion? Diesen Mini-Laptop?
Man würde jetzt vielleicht Netbook sagen.
Ihr hättet wohl mal Netbook sagen, genau.
Na, wie hieß denn das Teil?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es hieß, auf jeden Fall, es war so ein Mini-Laptop, den man sich zu seinem Palm oder Windows-Smartphone dazu kaufen sollte, damit man dann E-Mails auf dem großen Display lesen kann, endlich mal. Weil die von Palm festgestellt haben, es gibt einfach keine Geräte, mit denen man auf einem großen Display seine...
Genau, und der kam aber nicht raus.
Aber als sie das Ding angekündigt haben, da hab ich gedacht, okay, jetzt ist es vorbei. Jetzt können sie den Laden auch dicht machen, oder?
Ich hatte ähnliche Gefühle.
Und dann haben sie ihn ja selber zurückgerufen. Das war ja noch ganz schick, da hat Gizmodo, glaube ich, Engagert oder Gizmodo, hat das Ding fertig gemacht in dem Artikel. Und als Antwort kam von dem Palm-CEO irgendwie ein paar Wochen später, ihr hattet übrigens Recht.
Einsicht ist ja ganz hilfreich. Wenn man sie hat.
Genau. Also aber Palm ist eine Firma, die am Anfang Großes getan hat, dann immer größer wurde. Und dann, damit sie überhaupt ein Smartphone hatten, mussten sie ja schon Handspring aufkaufen. Also da war es ja schon ein bisschen so, uuuh.
Ein permanentes Hin und Her. Sie sind immer wieder darauf angewiesen, sich extern die Innovationsfreude wieder reinzuholen.
Und es ging ihnen ein Stück weit so wie Apple 1997. Die guten Jahre sind vorbei, die glanzvollen Zeiten, davon profitiert man noch ein bisschen. Aber eigentlich sind sie am Ende. Und dann kommen sie zu CS mit diesem Prä.
Und was haben sie gemacht? Sie haben sich mal wieder bei Apple bedient.
Sie haben das iPhone genommen und geguckt, was ist am iPhone geil, das machen wir nach. Und was ist am iPhone scheiße, das machen wir besser.
Du hast sicherlich jetzt auch diese Keynote gesehen.
Ich hab die gesehen, verständlich gesehen.
Die war ja insofern schon mal relativ bemerkenswert, als dass sie nicht total langweilig war. Also dieser, man merkt den Rubin Stein, also der jetzt sozusagen dafür verantwortlich sein...
Dessen Stimme man auch kannte, wenn man schon mal eine Apple Keynote gesehen hat.
Der war auch schon mal on stage.
So mit dem iPod und so.
Der war früher auch der, der die iPod-Abteilung......geleitet.
Das ist sozusagen sein Werk. Mit anderen Worten, der versteht schon sehr viel davon, was es bedeutet, ein Device in die Hände von Menschen zu legen und welche Abwägungen dort getroffen werden sollen. Also sie haben sich damit wirklich, naja, ich meine, nicht, dass ich jetzt einen Überblick hätte, aber schon einen der besseren auf den Markt geholt. Direkt vom mexikanischen Strand, wie er ja betont hat.
Nein, nicht nur das. Also es gab ja mal, es gab ja so die Geschichten eben, dass Steve Jobs ja schon ganz böse bei Palm angerufen haben soll und die dann mal schön zusammengeschrien haben, weil die wohl sich so in der iPhone- und iPod-Abteilung bedient haben, was die Mitarbeiter angeht. Also dass da wohl Dutzende Apple-Entwickler von Palm direkt abgeworben worden sind.
Abgeworben?
Abgeworben worden sind. Und die dann alle an diesem Gerät offensichtlich mit drin gearbeitet haben.
Man kriegt so den Eindruck, weil es gibt doch eine ganze Menge Details, die wirklich eine 1 zu 1 Kopie des iPhone-User-Interfaces sind. Ich sag mal so, wir scrollen durch eine Liste und ich weiß nicht, bummt das auch am Schluss?
So viele Details hab ich ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht gesehen.
Aber so mal diese Ackselration und dass es langsamer wird und so weiter. Das ist auf jeden Fall mit drin. Wobei ich auch sagen würde, das nicht zu kopieren wäre dumm. ist einfach ein Fehler. Also ich gucke richtig blöd, wenn irgendein System das nicht macht. Was war das letzte System? Android, genau.
Das dürfte man, also für ein gutes Gerät dürfte das Thema State of the Art sein.
Auf dem G1 ist das nicht so. Oder täusche mich jetzt gerade, verwechsel ich das mit irgendwas anderem, was ich noch in der Hand hatte? Was hatte ich denn noch in der Hand? Ok, also ein bisschen Beweis des Gegenteils, sage ich jetzt mal, dass es das war. Auf jeden Fall gibt es solche Systeme und man kommt sich irgendwie komplett bekloppt vor, wenn da keine Acceleration drin ist. Naja, wollen wir mal ein bisschen, ich habe mir ein paar Notizen gemacht.
Zum Prä?
Ja, habe ich gemacht. Was mir so gefiel und was mir nicht so gefiel.
Also fang mal an, dann kann ich immer...
Erste Notiz war, weitgehende Kopie des iPhones. Naja, das war jetzt gut. Also warum eben, was ich eben gerade gesagt habe, also diese Elemente. Was ich diesem Gerät auch nicht vorwerfen würde. Sie haben einfach eine ganze Menge kapiert, denke ich mal. Was ich ein bisschen komisch finde, ist dieser komische Off-Screen-Gesture-Bereich. Also sie haben ja das Display und einen kapazitiven Screen nehme ich mal an. Hab ich so explizit nicht gelesen, aber ich habe auch nichts Gegenteiliges gelesen.
Ich glaube, das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Multi-Touch-Screen, ziemlich sicher.
Stimmt, haben sie gesagt.
Ich bin mit.
Dann ist es ein kapazitiver. So, und dann gibt es darunter halt auch noch diesen Bereich, der unbeschriftet ist, aber den man halt auch noch mit benutzen kann.
Da, wo beim klassischen Pan sozusagen die Tasten liegen.
Genau, und da kann man halt Gesten machen, die sozusagen in den Screen gehen. Also dadurch, dass man von Offscreen in den Screen hineingestikuliert.
Es gibt auch die einfache Zurückgeste, die komplett unten abläuft. Also wo man dann quasi unten da, wo beim iPhone der eine Homebutton ist, wenn man dann links daneben macht, so flickt man so ein bisschen mit dem Finger rüber und dann geht er halt zurück oder nach vorwärts.
Genau. Das heißt, sie haben, und an der Stelle wird es jetzt auch wirklich, frage ich mich, wie wird das dann auch in der Software abgebildet? Weil, wenn ich jetzt den Screen habe und dann habe ich aber nochmal die, also ist die Geste dann sozusagen vollständig entkoppelt von der Position dadurch? Oder ist das ein Screen, auf dem man nichts anzeigt? Also wie ist das für die Software?
Also ich nehme an, für die Software wird das so sein, dass die da so, also da sind ja so vier LEDs, glaube ich, unten. Also man hat quasi kein Feedback hier in dem Bereich, außer eben durch vier LEDs, die drunter sind. Und das nochmal so ein bisschen andeuten. Also wenn man so eine Rückwärtsbewegung gemacht hat, dann leuchtet die mal kurz auf.
Ach wirklich?
Das konnte man auch relativ schön sehen. Und ich nehme mal an, dass da auch nicht so unglaublich, also dass da nicht so richtig viele Sensoren unten drunter sein werden. Sodass die Software wahrscheinlich nur zurückliefert, jetzt war so eine Geste von Position 2 auf Position 1 oder jetzt war eine Geste von Position 4 auf Position 1. Also das ist da gar nicht so, dass man da gar nicht pixelgenau auswerten kann.
Verstehe, dass das jetzt nicht so eine volle Auflösung ist, wie jetzt der Screen, sondern nur so ein...
Ist jetzt reine Vermutung, aber......ist geraten. Ja. Und die einzige Geste, die man nach oben machen konnte, das war diese, dass man dann aus dem Bereich die Buttons rein geholt hat. Quasi dieses Safari-Doc unten.
Das ist Launching, ne?
Das konnte man dann quasi ein bisschen reinziehen. Das fand ich...
Man kann ja überhaupt allerlei durcheinander wirbeln. Also, wie auch immer. Ich will es noch nicht abschließend bewerten. Mein erster Gedanke, den ich hatte in dem Moment, war, was bauen sie denn da noch alles rein? Das wird ja ganz schön teuer. Ja, also den Screen und dann noch irgendwie diese Sensorik und das sind halt alles Sachen, die den Preis erhöhen. Damit müssen die leben. Also, ich verstehe, was sie damit gewinnen. Sie gewinnen sozusagen Gesten, die sehr eindeutig sind. Ich frage mich allerdings, ob es nun wirklich so schwierig ist, dass man das nicht auch hätte mit einem Screen machen können. Also so eine Zurückgeste, das muss ja auch mit dem Screen gehen. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt in meinem Classics, in meinem E-Book-Reader...
Da hat man ja auch solche Gesten, klar.
Da hab ich auch solche Gesten, die kann man irgendwie auch erkennen. Man hätte ja auch mit Zweifingertouch oder sowas machen können.
Ja, das ist kein Mast. Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen was Neues zu haben.
Ja, und das legt auch eine gewisse Komplexität dann einerseits, ist auch fair, andererseits auch in das User-Interface, weil du musst dir dann sozusagen auch merken, wo du jetzt was machst.
Also was daran auf jeden Fall doof ist, wenn man so eine Geste in so einem unteren Bereich macht, das fiel mir, als sich dieses Android-Phone von Google das erste Mal in der Hand hielt. Das iPhone hat ja genau diese eine Taste und man weiß immer, was sie genau als Nächstes macht. Sie führt einem immer wieder auf diesen einen Bildschirm zurück. Und darum ist es okay und darum gewöhnt man sich relativ schnell an diese Taste. Bei diesem Android-Phone, wie komme ich im Browser eigentlich zurück? Ah, da gibt es einen Back-Button auf der Hardware. Aber den vergisst man immer, weil man guckt ja nur aufs Display. Man guckt ja nicht auf die Hardware. Es gibt da einen Back-Button, es gibt da einen Auflegen-Button, Home-Button, Back-Button. Auf Abheben-Button. Und so ähnlich könnte es natürlich mit dieser Geste sein. Wobei, wenn man es einmal intuitiv drauf hat, nicht intuitiv, sondern wenn man es einmal gelernt hat, ist es, glaube ich, eine Geste, die man auch blind bedienen kann. Insofern kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass die dauerhafte Produktivität, brauchst du nicht zwei Finger nehmen, weißt du? Also darauf haben sie ja sehr viel Wert gelebt, auf die Ein-Hand-Bedienung.
Der Power-User, wobei ich da mit der Ein-Hand-Bedienung auf dem iPhone jetzt auch nicht so...
Ja, wenn du das mit zwei Fingern machen würdest, wäre das schon problematisch.
Das geht auch noch mit einer Hand.
So, eine Hand halten? Und wie jetzt mit zwei Fingern?
Ach so, mit einer Hand im Sinne von auch nur in einer Hand halten und dabei bedienen. Das stimmt.
Dafür ist es auf jeden Fall ganz gut.
Na gut, aber man könnte das auch mit einem Finger machen, wie auch immer. Blablabla. Ich bin gespannt, welchen Grad an Komplexität das letzten Endes im Resultat hat. Und ich könnte mir einfach vorstellen, dass es auch verwirrend sein kann. Weil du hast sozusagen explizit Gestenbereich und Multitouch im User-Interface auf dem Screen. Mit unterschiedlichen Bedingungen, Bereichen. Das eine hat einen Bildschirm, wo du einen Visual Feedback geben kannst, das andere hat das nicht. Halt dich auch für problematisch. Klar, es ist so ein bisschen das Echo des Stiftes. Es ist so ein bisschen so dieses, du hast noch was anderes in deinem User-Interface, außer nur dich und dem Bildschirm.
Das haben sie auch explizit in der Keynote gesagt, dass das der Bereich ist, in dem die Buttons vorher sind und den wollten wir unseren User nicht wegnehmen und weiß der Teufel was. Aber sie kennen das auch schon.
Ja, da kommen sie her. Das fanden sie gut. Damit sahen sie irgendwie die Möglichkeiten. Wir werden es sehen. Das wird sich zeigen.
Was ich großartig fand...
Dann haben sie auch Autorotate eingebaut, beim iPhone.
Geklaut.
Hab ich schon mal über Autorotate explizit?
Ja, ich glaube schon das eine oder andere Mal.
Es geht so ein bisschen.
Du magst es nicht?
Ich finde es furchtbar. Ich will auch meinen Computer im Liegen benutzen. Das schließt es einfach aus. Meine Coverflow auf dem iPhone ist einfach mal der Sack. Das mir beliebige Programm, weil die Gravitation gerade von links kommt, ein anderes User-Interface präsentieren, vielleicht auch in einem komplett anderen Daten-Kontext. Wenn es das selbe User-Interface in Breit wäre, dann ist es ja okay. Aber es ist ja auch was komplett anderes manchmal.
Nur beim iPod, oder? Also beim iPod finde ich es ganz furchtbar. Dieses Coverflow, das ist ein reines Demo-Feature. Das zeigt man einmal irgendwelchen Leuten, die noch nie ein iPhone gesehen haben, und dann freuen die sich ganz toll. Aber da könnte man genauso gut Google Maps zeigen, was wirklich eine praktische Anwendung ist.
Ich will ja gar nicht sagen, dass es nicht toll ist zum Musik auswählen, aber ich wähle nie Musik aus.
Ich wähle ständig Musik aus und ich nutze das nie. Nee, das ist einfach, dass das Coverflow ist hübsch, das macht was her, aber auch keine Sau.
Ich hätte ja nichts dagegen, wenn es so eine Rotationsgeste gäbe. So, was weiß ich, dreh die Finger im Kreis oder so. Und dann schnapp ich halt auf Landscape-Modus um, dass ich einfach Auto-Rotate ausschalten kann in den Präferenzen. Und dann kann ich einfach selber wählen, ob ich jetzt meinen Computer in Landscape oder nicht benutzen möchte. Zumal in allen Programmen, wo ich es gerne hätte, geht es nicht. Was weiß ich, so Maps oder so. Also es ist auch irgendwie alles beknackt.
Ja, das ist, das ist, das müssen sie auf jeden Fall besser, also das müssen sie bei diesen Paaren prägen, so was war besser in Krieg.
Ja, sieht aber nicht so aus. Also sie haben auch Auto-Rotate und ich denke, sie werden die gleichen Probleme ernten, auch wenn sie vielleicht sich den Coverflow sparen, weil sie irgendwie ähnlich so mit Musik und so weiter sind.
Was sie haben, was das iPhone nicht hat, das andere Multi, das Tasking. Guck mal, war das nicht lustig formuliert?
Na ja, Multitasking haben sie, aber sie haben es halt. Multitasking hat auch das iPhone, aber sie haben es...
Im User-Interface, Multitasking-User-Interface. Und das finde ich ist wirklich... Ich finde, die Gründe, warum Apple das nicht gemacht hat, sind absolut nachvollziehbar. Aber so wie die das gelöst haben, ist das echt ziemlich...
Bisher nicht gemacht hat.
Bisher nicht gemacht hat. Also Apple, Palm hat sich genug bei dir abgeguckt, guck ruhig mal in die andere Richtung ab.
Was hast du denn da gesehen? Also was ich gesehen habe, ist, es gab da irgendwie vier Anwendungen. Telefon, Notizbuch oder so. Was war das?
Also wir haben Adressbuch. Was gab's denn da? Adressbuch gab's ja gar nicht. Das ist ja auch ein anderer schöner Vorteil, dieses Messaging, dieses Unified-Messaging sozusagen.
Ich meine, was wird passieren, wenn du dann dein zehntes Programm gestartet hast und der RAM ist voll auf deinem Telefon?
Was passiert dann?
Das haben sie nicht gezeigt.
Das haben sie nicht gezeigt. Ich habe aber eine Theorie, dass das vielleicht tatsächlich gar nicht so ein gigantisches Problem werden könnte.
Weil?
Weil, Sie haben ja gesagt, aber das ist jetzt wirklich reine Theorie. Also es ist ja angekündigt, dass es, was ich auch eine sehr schöne Sache finde, es gibt ja kein natives GUI, sozusagen, für dieses Time-Play-Gerät. Sondern es ist ja rein WebKit basiert. Also es ist genauso wie Safari auf dem iPhone, genauso wie Android, genauso wie Nokia, genauso wie alle das WebKit eingesetzt von Apple. Für die HTML-Darstellung.
Mit einem Unterschied.
Aber für alles. Nicht nur für Safari, sondern für jedes Element, das man auf dem Bildschirm sieht, wird WebKit eingesetzt. Und damit hast du eine Webseite, die du offen hast, die ganze Zeit über. Und ich kann mir jetzt vorstellen, dass die einfach Folgendes machen, bei so einem Adressbuch. Was hast du da großartig? Da hast du so ein Webview, da hast du ein bisschen HTML, da hast du ein bisschen JavaScript. Und hin und wieder musst du mal Daten in eine Datenbank speichern oder eben daraus auslesen. Was wäre denn, wenn die quasi das so ein bisschen machen wie eine Web-Applikation? Du hast auf dem Gerät direkt einen kleinen Web-Server drauf. Und nur, sobald, wenn tatsächlich eine Anfrage kommt, in Anführungsstrichen, also wenn ich gerade in meinen Adressen suche oder so was, nur dann wird die Applikation gestartet, liefert mir ein Ergebnis zurück und schläft wieder ein. Dann könnte man nämlich einfach, wenn man den 10. oder 20. Tab aufmacht, killst du einfach im Hintergrund diese Applikation. Und schon hast du nur noch da mal einen MP3-Demon, der noch ein bisschen rumläuft oder so was.
Also du meinst, du machst das genauso wie Apple, bloß du zeigst es nach wie vor in dieser Task-Auswahl User Interface an.
Genau, du zeigst es genauso an, machst quasi in Anführungsstrichen Screenshot davon. Und wenn das dann wieder nach vorne geholt wird, also das machen sie nicht, weil es ist ja auch interaktiv der Bereich, aber...
Aber sie haben ja gezeigt, dass die Programme noch laufen. Und sie haben ja auch gesagt, das ist jetzt hier Multitasking. Ich meine, wenn sie das dann so machen, dann...
Ja, aber ich meine, sie machen einfach mehrere Taps auf dem Browser. Genauso wie Safari auch schon mehrere Taps aufmachen kann, bloß noch nicht so hübsch.
Ja, Browser und so. Also ich meine, man muss, glaube ich, zwei Sachen unterscheiden. Also sie basieren zwar auf WebKit und ihr, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ihr Development-Modell basiert jetzt auf JavaScript. Das heißt, sie sagen, du willst entwickeln für den Pre, deine Programmiersprache heißt JavaScript.
Sicherlich nicht, nur, aber die primäre Programmiersprache schon.
Ich wüsste nicht, welche Sprache jetzt noch zum Einsatz kommen sollte.
Du musst ja auch irgendwie einen MP3-Player beschreiben können.
Ja, oder mal ein Video abspielen.
Oder mal ein Video abspielen oder sowas in der Richtung.
Das macht dann die Hardware.
Ja, aber spätestens.
Das macht auch auf dem iPhone die Hardware.
So ein Java-Client dürfte mittlerweile in JavaScript möglich sein.
Natürlich ist das alles möglich in JavaScript. Das ist eine richtig coole Programmiersprache.
Wenn du die entsprechenden APIs bietest, klar. Entweder haben sie die APIs komplett nachgebaut oder...
Die APIs musst du in jeder Programmiersprache bereitstellen. Das ist kein besonderes Problem von JavaScript. JavaScript ist nur eine andere Programmiersprache, die by default noch nicht in Anführungsstrichen Native Speed bietet. Nur da kommen wir jetzt hin. Die neue Webkit-Version mit Squirrelfish usw. Die gehen in die Richtung, Native Speed sich anzunähern. Native im Sinne von das, was wir jetzt mit einem C-Programm, was explizit für diesen Prozessor kompiliert ist.
Mit dieser Just-in-time-Kompilation.
Das geht ja schon weiter. Das in time ist richtig. Aber nur, dass sie keinen Zwischencode mehr machen, sondern dass sie richtig Native Code daraus machen.
Das ist zumindest die Open-Source-Lösung, die es bisher so gibt, von Google und von Apple. Das basieren alle ausschließlich auf dem x86. Und zwar auch nicht mal auf dem x64, sondern alle auf dem x86. Aber sie arbeiten auch an Arm. Klar, arbeiten die da dran. Aber vielleicht haben sie es ja schon. Also ich bilde mir ein, irgendwo gehört zu haben, dass es quasi unten drunter auch noch eine klassische CAP geben soll. Bin jetzt aber gar nicht ehrlich gesagt 100% sicher. Aber ich glaube, sie haben gesagt, fürs GUI explizit HTML, CSS und JavaScript.
Aber viel gesagt haben sie nicht. Sie haben nur gesagt, unser OS heißt jetzt WebOS. Was sie nicht gesagt haben ist Linux. Aber das ist es.
Es ist ein Linux, genau.
Es ist ein Linux-System mit WebKit drauf. Also im Kern genau dasselbe, was Android auch macht. Nur, dass Android halt auf Java setzt mit einer eigenen Engine. Und sie setzen halt auf JavaScript mit WebKit im Wesentlichen. Ob sie da jetzt noch auch an dem JavaScript-Ligen rumgefummelt haben, weiß ich nicht. Ich wage das aber auszuschließen, weil ob das nun wirklich die Kernkompetenz ist, das glaube ich nicht.
Sie müssen nochmal eine fette Optimierung reingepackt haben, weil jetzt diese ganzen Tester, die es in der Hand gehalten haben, haben nochmal gesagt, ich bin mit dem Ding gesurft im Netz und es war nochmal einen Zacken schneller als auf dem iPhone.
Achso, der Webbrowser in dem Sinne ist ja nicht in JavaScript geschrieben.
Aber sie haben offensichtlich nochmal richtig fette Optimierung reingepackt, die nochmal sogar über die Optimierung von Apple hinausgeht. Vielleicht haben sie auch einfach eine neuere WebKit-Version gehabt, kann natürlich auch sein.
Das kann sehr wohl sein, dass sie einfach eine neuere Version genommen haben. Kennst du die Specs? Weißt du, auf welcher Taktrate und so weiter dieses Teil läuft? Dieses Demo-Teil, wie gut konnten die das testen? Hatten die das so richtig für ein paar Tage in der Hand?
Für ein paar Tage nicht, für da in der Hand.
So, mal kurz hier, darfst du es mal in die Hand nehmen? Jetzt gibt es es mir wieder her.
Nee, es gibt bei Gizmodo und so halbstündige Videos angeguckt, wo es auf den Dingern rumgespielt hat.
Okay, aber nicht mit irgendwie Akkulaufzeit über drei Tage?
Also schon so mit, da sitzt jemand von den Leuten daneben, der auch freundlich einschreitet, aber sieht man nicht.
Okay, also es ist nur so user-interface-Tests, wir wissen jetzt zum Beispiel nicht, wie die Battery-Drain war.
Genau, das wissen wir nicht.
Weil das ist natürlich dann die große Frage.
Das wird furchtbar sein, stelle ich mir auch so vor.
Das ist auch ein Bereich, wo man sagen muss, wissen wir nicht. Prozessor ist arm.
Was natürlich an diesem...
Oder, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob ich eine konkrete Referenz gelesen habe. Ich glaube, das war eher eine Vermutung von mir.
Was ich mal kurz dazwischen sagen möchte, so sehr ich wie ich HTML, CSS und JavaScript auch liebe, wo es natürlich wirklich auch mit vielen guten Zureden am Ende ist, ist bei 3D-Darstellung. Spiele werden auch auf dem Palm in irgendwas C-artigen geschrieben werden, noch auf absehbare Zeit, behaupte ich mal.
Behauptest du?
Behaupte ich.
Das kann gut sein. Ich habe auch nicht den Eindruck, dass sie hier vorhaben, eine Spieleplattform zu bieten. Ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet letzten Endes für dieses Ding. Ich meine, ich denke, Apple muss sich vor diesem Telefon derzeit überhaupt nicht fürchten. Also weder haben sie eine große, loyale Customer Base, weil die haben sie weitgehend eingebüßt, mit der sie da jetzt groß pfunden könnten. Im Idealfall schaffen sie es, ihren Kundenstamm zu halten. Also ich würde, nein, im Idealfall schaffen sie es, ihn noch auszubauen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie da sehr weit kommen werden im ersten Jahr. Zumal das Ding ja auch erst wann rauskommt, jetzt im Juni oder so. Mitte des Jahres, haben sie glaube ich gesagt. So, und dann muss man erstmal gucken, mit welchem Problem das Ding an den Start kommt.
Also ich habe bei einigen Sachen Bauchschmerzen, was das Gerät angeht. Zum einen wird es erstmal nur bei Sprint in Amerika zur Verfügung stehen. Weil es kein GSM und auch kein OMTS-Chip drin hat, sondern dieses, wie heißt das, EFDO-Netzwerk? Mit allen Worten, sie müssen die Hardware ändern, um das Gerät überhaupt außerhalb von Amerika vertreiben zu können. Das werden sie natürlich machen, aber das wird bestimmt noch ein bisschen dauern.
Das ist auch wieder so Dual Development, nicht? Also, ich meine, das ist vielleicht zu schaffen, aber...
Ja, und anstatt, also ich meine, das ist ja eine der geilen Sachen von diesem iPhone, dass das weltweit absolut identisch ist. Da packst du eine andere Bedienungsanleitung dazu. Und ansonsten ist das überall das gleiche Gerätweise auf das Hardware-Keyboard verzichten. Und das haben sie sich alles mit eingekauft. Sie müssen unter Umständen den Radiochip auswechseln für andere Länder. Und sie müssen überall eine eigene Tastatur einbauen. Zum Zweiten wird der Preis dem Vernehmen nachher ziemlich hoch sein. Also es gab ja, offiziell gibt es noch keinen Preis, klar. Aber es gab ja Sprüche von wegen, wie teuer wird es ungefähr so sein? So 200 Euro, um mit dem iPhone vergleichbar zu sein. Und da soll Rubinstein wohl sehr nach Steve Jobs-Manier gesagt haben. Ach, der Chef.
Warum sollten wir es billiger verkaufen, wenn wir ein besseres...
Warum sollten wir das überlegene Gerät billig verkaufen, oder genau so teuer verkaufen?
Das war natürlich schon ein bisschen... Das ist auf die Kacke gehauen.
Das ist eine ziemliche Arroganz, aber das deutet so ein Stück weit darauf hin, dass wir erstmal einen ziemlichen Premium-Preis haben wollen. Und das ist...
Steve Jobs wird gelächelt haben in diesem Moment.
Ich würde sagen, das ist der Moment, in dem er...
Ich glaube nicht, dass er wirklich Angst hat.
Nein, Angst haben brauchen wir auch nicht, weil damit werden sie nicht auf Oloom kommen. Ich glaube, das ist ein Markt, in dem es jetzt... Meine Vorhersage ist, Google wird den Markt dominieren. Das hat überhaupt gar nichts damit zu tun.
Welchen Markt?
Diesen Mobilgeräte-Markt.
Mobiltelefone, Smartphones meinst du? Einschließlich oder ausschließlich des iPhones?
Das iPhone wird, glaube ich, in zwei, drei Jahren nur noch eine Nebenrolle spielen.
Oh, wirklich?
Ja.
Na, da haben wir ja mal wieder eine Kiste Mate zu verteilen.
Da haben wir mal wieder eine Kiste Mate zu verteilen. Und zwar einfach aus dem Grund, was ich zur CES gehört habe, da war, wenn man mal die üblichen verdächtigen Quellen durchgegangen ist, Gizmodo in Gadget, Android hier, Android da, ein iPod-Touch-artiges Gerät mit Android drauf, ein überdimensionales Tischtelefon mit Android drauf. Und natürlich kommt kein einzelnes von diesen Geräten auch eine Ansatzweise ans iPhone ran. Aber es wird eine so unglaublich große Auswahl an Android-Telefonen geben, innerhalb von kürzester Zeit, die dann auch irgendwelchen Corporate-Ansprüchen gerecht werden und weiß der Teufel was, dass Apple mit diesem exakt ein Gerät, was es in zwei verschiedenen Farben gibt, ich glaube, Apple wird dagegen echte Massenprobleme haben.
Ich sag dir mal, was Apple hat, was die anderen nicht haben. Und was ich glaube, was wirklich, wirklich wichtig ist.
Was haben sie?
iPod.
Das iPhone ist auch ein iPod. Und es gibt nichts auf dem Markt, was es derzeit mit dem iPod aufnehmen kann. Und Musik ist einfach wichtig. Und über Musik habe ich jetzt hier auch wenig... Wo ist der Music Player? Warum haben sie den nicht gezeigt?
Den haben sie gezeigt.
Haben sie den gezeigt?
Aber nicht in dieser Keynote.
Vielleicht nicht mehr Keynote, sondern in den anderen Demos. Der ist Coverflow inspiriert. Sieht ein bisschen hübsch aus.
Und womit singt der?
Das weiß ich nicht. Was er hat, was ganz großartig ist, ist diese Notification-Funktion. Wenn eine neue SMS kommt, während man gerade irgendwas anderes macht, wird nicht etwa...
Oh ja, das schiebt sich in den Screen rein und so.
Da wird nicht alles überdeckt und drückt jetzt einen Button, bevor du auch deine SMS abschicken kannst. Sondern das Display wird unten hin kleiner und es wird unten klein eingeblendet, was gerade abläuft. Und da taucht alles auf. Da taucht mein Google Talk drin auf. Da taucht mein neue Mails auf. Da tauchen meine SMS auf. Und da taucht auch der MP3-Player auf, wenn er gerade MP3s abspielt. Und dann hast du nämlich noch so kleine Tasten, mit denen du da jederzeit den MP3-Player noch mal ein bisschen steuern kannst und wurde dann so ganz kleines Coverbildchen eingeblendet, siehst.
Und ein klattert User Interface hast.
Darauf bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wie das aussehen wird, wenn man dann irgendwie unten der 20 Notifications auf einmal hat, ob da nicht irgendwann mal das Display weg ist.
Das ist nicht so ohne Probleme.
Das ist nicht ohne Probleme, aber es ist erstmal... Also sie haben das Problem, was ich jeden Tag habe, wenn ich mein iPhone benutze, haben sie erkannt, weil sie wahrscheinlich alle selber ein iPhone haben und haben es erstmal, zumindest auf den ersten Blick, eine relativ elegante Lösung dafür gefunden.
Ja, aber ich denke einfach, iTunes spielt einfach nach wie vor eine Riesenrolle und man kann die Marktdominanz von iTunes gerade nicht unterschätzen. Also ich meine, sie sind jetzt einfach die Number One auf eine Art und Weise, wie die anderen einfach auch nicht nur im Ansatz eine Chance haben. Und vor allem diese Kette von Verkauf, Download, also Store, Auswahl, Kaufen, auf dem Computer und vor allem das Sinken. Ich meine, man kann über iTunes eine Menge schimpfen, haben wir ja auch schon gemacht, werden wir sicherlich auch noch häufig tun. Nur bis heute ist es einfach niemandem gelungen, diese relativ simple Kette einfach nachzubauen. Und Palm, naja, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, wenn sie irgendwie anfangen, jetzt Sinking für einen Macintosh zu machen, was dabei rauskommt.
Ich glaube, die probieren gar nicht mehr, Sinking für einen Macintosh zu machen. Ich glaube, die werden...
Ja, wo ist denn dann deine Musik? Deine Musik ist aber auf deinem Computer.
Also wie man die bereits vorhandene Musik draufkriegt, das ist tatsächlich eine spannende Frage. Das wird man dann sehen, wenn es soweit ist. Aber ich glaube, die werden... Also was den Neukauf von Musik angeht und von Programmen werden sie einfach ausschließlich über die Luft gehen und das Synchronisieren von Adresse und Kontaktler wird auch über die Luft gehen.
Amazon, ja, aber irgendwo muss ja auch dein Storage sein. Heißt das, dass deine Musik dann auch im Internet gespeichert wird für dich? Kaufst du bei Amazon und speicherst du es dann gleich bei S3 sozusagen?
Wäre eigentlich mal eine geile Option, oder?
Ja, dann zahlt man wenigstens auch noch regelmäßig für seine Musik.
Kennst du Spotify? Hättest du noch mal ganz zwischendurch kurz? Das ist ja so eine Art iTunes im Netz. Ziemlich schick.
Ja, hab ich von gehört, lass uns mal nicht die Palm-Pri-Diskussion jetzt verwässern, aber wie auch immer. Also egal, mit was sie da kommen, ob das dann greift und ob das von den benutzten akzeptiert wird, das muss ich erst nochmal zeigen und bislang weiß man eigentlich noch gar nichts. Und sie wissen auch ansonsten eine ganze Menge nicht. Das hat man eben auch daran gesehen, wonach sie eben gefragt haben. Ich meine, es ist vollkommen unklar, was ist mit Spielen, was ist mit Native? Ich hab irgendwas im Ohr, dass sie auch Flash bringen wollen. Oh Gott, damit haben sie natürlich den Belzebub irgendwie in ihr System.
Na ja, also zum einen, auf den Demogeräten da ging Flash definitiv nicht und zum zweiten, falls das die Auskunft war, die sie gefragt haben, dann war das nämlich, dass sie so einen Mädel auf dem Stand gefragt haben. Also das tauchte in dem Video auf der Helm, hat das Ding eigentlich auch Flash. Und die nicht wusste, was Flash ist, offensichtlich. Und ansonsten relativ gut Bescheid. Dann haben die gefragt, kann das so YouTube und sowas? Und daraus ist, glaube ich, gemacht worden, das Ding kann Flash. Ich glaube, die haben, genauso wie auf dem iPhone, einfach nochmal einen YouTube-Player dabei.
Die nehmen jetzt auch alle H264. Die wären ja doof.
Also ich meine, wenn man da irgendwie über Flash YouTube-Videos abspielt, wie bescheuert wäre das denn?
Genau, also das, gut, dann weiß ich jetzt nicht, was da wirklich angekündigt worden ist. Was ich noch bemerkenswert fand, ist, dass sie gleich vom Start mit Instant-Messaging losgehen. Wenn man sich jetzt so anschaut, hier neuer Telekom-Tarif, der Versuch hier irgendwie für Androiden Tarif in Deutschland anzubieten und dann vielleicht auch fürs iPhone und mit irgendwie Jahr und dann für 5 Euro im Monat darfst du auch Instant-Messaging benutzen. Irgendwie sowas hab ich gelesen. Mich hat das total verwirrt, dieser Post dabei, FSCKlog, der versucht hat, so einen Überblick über diese Tarifgeschichte.
Über diese vereinfachten Tarife bei T-Mobile.
Ich hab da gleich bei der Hälfte wieder abgebrochen, weil ich dachte, das geht nicht in mein Hirn.
Das bringt die Mobilfunkmärzte durcheinander.
Sie setzen da sehr viel mehr drauf. Wenn sie jetzt wirklich mit ihrem Multitasking da herkommen, dann könnte das wirklich auch was bringen. Und was haben wir noch? Dieses Combined Address Book. Ihr Versuch, ob das dann auch funktioniert, das wird sich noch mal zeigen. Du hast deine Kontakte in Facebook, du hast deine Kontakte auf Google, du hast deine Kontakte auf was weiß ich. Und sie versuchen das, ich sag jetzt mal sie versuchen es, weil ob sie es schaffen werden, das wird sich zeigen, weil bei der Demo natürlich alles perfekt, diese Dinge zusammenzubringen. Das ist eigentlich eine schöne Idee.
Das ist eine großartige Idee. Auf die ich jetzt da sitze, auf meinem dämlichen iPhone und dann feststelle, dass ich die Telefonnummer doch nicht im Addressbuch habe, sondern jetzt noch das Zinkprogramm starten muss, das nervt. Das geht besser. Da hat Apple was nicht verstanden, was Palm verstanden hat, nämlich, dass man viele Dinge heutzutage in den Netz macht.
Naja, du weißt auch, wie es ist bei Apple. Es gibt so Features, die haben die durchaus im Blick, aber die sagen einfach, das lassen wir jetzt erstmal weg. Und dann gucken wir mal, wie sehr sie alle leiden und ob es wirklich das Problem ist. Weil, sind nicht alle schon für Features aufgezählt worden, was das iPhone unbedingt haben muss, damit es ein Erfolg wird und es hat es bis heute nicht und es ist jetzt schon ein Erfolg. Von daher sehe ich das auch sehr entspannt.
Ein Feature hat Parampere, was das iPhone auch nicht hat.
Und das ist?
Copy und Paste.
Haben sie das?
Das haben sie.
Haben sie das auch gezeigt?
Gezeigt haben sie es nicht, sie haben es nur erwähnt. Wolltest du jetzt auf den tauschbaren Akku hinaus?
Nee, den haben sie auch.
Wir haben auch einen tauschbaren Akku. Das ist ja was, worauf ich jetzt... Naja, aber die Ladeschale ist hübsch, oder?
Das ist wahr. Und das ist auch, glaube ich, das ist das, wo sich Steve Jobs geangert hat. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie das...
Das will er auch haben, das will er morgen auf der Schachtel schauen.
Das Ding hat sie bestimmt schon als Prototyp schon drei Jahre bei sich rumstehen.
Wahrscheinlich hat Rubiz dann das geklaut, als er gegangen ist.
Ja, ja, also aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
Hoppla, wo ist denn unsere Ladeschale hin?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen haben sie das nicht gebracht, weil, also mir wäre auch... Also mir würden da einige Gründe einfallen, warum nicht? Weil dieses Doc-Konzept, was Apple hat, hat ja auch seine Vorteile. Weil du lädst ja nicht nur, sondern du kriegst auch die Daten. Du kriegst auch die Daten. Und was sie halt denken, und ich denke, da liegen sie auch richtig, ist so dieses, du kommst mit deinem Telefon nach Hause, du steckst es einfach rein und damit ist alles getan. Laden, Sinken und so weiter. Und so hast du halt nur Laden und so weiter. Aber es sieht natürlich cool... Wie ist das? Das Ding wird von Magneten gehalten?
Also das ist, um es mal kurz zu sagen... Das ist eine Ladeschale, man braucht kein Kabel mehr reinzustecken.
Genau, das ist so ein rundes Teil, da steht Palm drauf. Und du legst das Telefon drauf, schwebt das dann?
Also es liegt drauf, aber es wird von Magneten in der richtigen Position gehalten. Du kannst es auch drehen. Du kannst es auch in die Horizontale bringen, weil es hat ja Acceleration drinnen. Ich glaube, das ist auch für den Executive-Schreibtisch gedacht. Der Winkel ist wohl perfekt, das haben sie auch in der Demo gezeigt. Dass du auch Filme gucken kannst.
Apple-Contact mit einer Ladeschale, wo das iPhone 5 cm über dieser Ladeschale schwebt und sinkt. Und dabei leuchtet.
Und dabei hab ich noch ein Hologramm, auf dem ich dann HD-Filme gucken kann.
Genau. Tod den Ungläubigen.
Nee, aber das ist echt... Also ich glaube, ich weiß nicht mal, ob ich es mir...
Video? Hast du irgendwas gesehen mit Wir können auch Videos abspielen? Sie sagten, YouTube geht.
Sie haben gesagt, YouTube geht. Und ich hab in der Demo auch ein Video gesehen. Da hatten sie Videos drauf. Ich glaube, da war ein YouTube-Video sogar. Also nicht in der Demo, die vorne auf der Bühne stattfand, sondern die ganzen Journalisten, die da drauf hatten.
Ich hab mir nur diese Keynote angeschaut.
Also da war hundertprozentig auch Video dabei. Da haben sie auch mal die Kamera vorgeführt, die gleich ein bisschen was Besseres ist als beim iPhone. Und erstaunlicherweise brauchte bei denen das Kameraprogramm nicht 48 Sekunden, bis es gestartet ist. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es möglich ist, auf dem Telefon eine Kamera zu starten, ohne dass es eine halbe Minute dauert.
Das ist in der Tat ein bisschen komisch. Und sie haben auch, glaube ich, eine halbwegs brauchbare Kamerageschichte eingebaut. Aber jetzt muss man auch erst mal sehen, was das Ding wirklich kann. 3 Megapixel, 3, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, das nächste iPhone wird das Kamerathema. Ich glaube, das ist beim nächsten iPhone. Zeit wird's. Ja, Zeit wird's und ich glaube, auch da können sie jetzt nicht dran vorbei.
Also ich, was ich jetzt unbedingt will fürs nächste iPhone ist, Apple kümmert euch um dieses scheiß Multitasking-Problem. Weil wenn man sich das mal genauer anguckt, so dieses, dass jeder RSS-Reader und jeder Twitter-Client noch einen eigenen Webbrowser mit eingebaut hat.
Warte mal, sind wir fertig mit dem Pri? Wollen wir jetzt sauer reden, was das iPhone, was dem noch so fehlt?
Ne, wir sind noch nicht komplett fertig.
Dann lass uns doch nochmal diesen Pri, ich meine, das hat natürlich ein bisschen auch was damit zu tun. Ich hab jetzt nicht mehr so viel. Ich meine, ich hab hier viele Fragezeichen. Was mit Games, was mit 3D, was mit Video. Hab ich halt nicht so viel gesehen. Was ist mit Musik? Was unterstützen sie für Formate? Davon war irgendwie einfach nicht die Rede. Ich denke mal, dass sie das auch einfach alles noch nicht sagen. Dann meinen sie ja, wir hätten ja auch gerne einen Upstore. Und fragen aber die Entwickler, was hätte die denn gerne?
Genau, da gibt es dieses Blog, dieses Entwickler-Blog, wo das angefangen wird, ein bisschen zu diskutieren.
Wo sie eine ganze Menge von diesen Sachen auch gefragt haben, die jetzt so beim iPhone auch immer noch wacky sind mit so Trial-Periods zum Beispiel für Software und so weiter, wie das die Developer sehen, Updates, wie das laufen soll. Gut, ich meine, da haben sie halt die Expertise nicht. Apple hat halt jetzt einfach schon angefangen. Und ich denke, die wissen jetzt schon ganz gut, was die Developer wollen, weil sie schreien ja dann immer sehr laut.
Ich glaube, die müssen auch sehr viel netter sein als Apple zu den Developern. Also ich meine, so ein iPhone.
Noch netter?
Noch netter, genau, noch netter als Apple zu den Entwicklern.
Haltet's Maul, erzählt keinem, was kauft.
Palm muss seine Entwickler wirklich pflegen, glaube ich. Jeder, der schon mal ein Computer bedient hat, oder schon mal Software entwickelt, hat sich ja sofort ein iPhone gekauft. Antworten dafür zu entwickeln, liegt in der Natur der Sache. Da ist man auch, glaube ich, bereit, einige Hürden zu überspringen. Aber der Palm Pre wird jetzt langsam die dritte interessante Plattform, für die es sich lohnt zu entwickeln. Und ich glaube, die müssen dann ihrer Entwickler wirklich schon, also die müssen dann auch für Entwickler schon günstigere Hardware ausliefern und sowas. Weil ansonsten, seh ich ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich nicht, wie die auf Masse kommen wollen.
Ja, das ist ein Unterscheidungsmerkmal. Ich meine, was ich so mitgenommen habe aus dieser Präsentation, was sich jetzt sozusagen unterscheidet von Apple und von Google im Wesentlichen, also weil sie sind die Einzigen, die jetzt vom User-Interface mithalten können.
Genau.
Microsoft ist einfach mal erstmal raus aus dem Spiel. Ich glaube, 2009 wird einfach ein ganz schlimmes Jahr werden. Für Microsoft Mobile, wohlgemerkt.
Und Steve Ballmer wird an die Decke gehen, als er das Ding gesehen hat.
Na, Steve Ballmer geht immer an die Decke.
Aber ich meine, das hat mir auch wirklich nochmal einen ordentlichen Schreck versetzt, dass eine relativ kleine Firma wie Palm das aus dem Boden stampft. Und Microsoft, wie lange hängen die jetzt rum und können mit ihrem scheiß Windows-Mobile nicht aus dem Arsch?
Aber ich muss auch sagen, diese Pre, ich glaube, sind so ein bisschen larger than life. Also, sie haben, meinten sie ja auch, sie haben ja total Glück gehabt, so, ah ja, Steve Jobs ist irgendwie weg und Erwartungen sind niedrig. Dadurch hatten sie, obwohl sie ja nur auf der CES waren, einfach das Limelight. Sie waren eigentlich die Einzigen, die wirklich irgendwas im Hardware-Sektor Neues gezeigt haben. Damit haben sie einfach schon mal sehr viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit gehabt. Das war, glaube ich, auch Glück. Und gut, aber was ich eben meinte, was ihr Einstellungsmerkmal ist, also das Einzige, was ich aus diesen Features, ich meine, mit diesem Multitasking, okay, meinetwegen Notifications und so. Das sind alles so ganz nette Sachen, aber das ist alles nichts, was Apple nicht mit dem nächsten Software Update einfach nachschieben kann und dann ist die Diskussion wieder woanders. Das Einzige, wo sie sich, glaube ich, für längere, für absehbare Zeit wirklich ganz deutlich unterscheiden werden, das ist dieser Ansatz mit, wir mögen alle. Du benutzt Google? Kein Problem. Du benutzt Facebook? Kein Problem. Du hast irgendwie deine eigene Adressbuch-Sammlung auf deinem Computer? Kriegen wir auch irgendwie noch rein. Wir integrieren das, wir sind agnostisch gegenüber demjenigen, der speichert. Android ist halt voll auf, also das Google-Phone ist zumindest auf Google. Jetzt muss man mal gucken, wenn andere Android rausbringen, wo jetzt nicht with Google ist, sondern without Google, was dann dieses System eigentlich zur leistenden Lage ist. Das wird man noch mal sehen. Aber grundsätzlich, Palm hat sozusagen den Vorteil des Außenseiters, dass sie eigentlich gar keine Infrastruktur haben. Sie haben irgendwie kein Mobile Me, sie haben kein Facebook, sie haben keine OS, sie haben einfach gar nichts außer diesen Geräten. Sie müssen eigentlich mit allem gut leben. Und sicherlich gibt es eine Klientel, die sagt, ich bin gerne unabhängig. Nicht viele Leute kaufen sich kein iPhone, nicht weil sie das Gerät nicht mögen, sondern weil sie einfach die Zentriertheit in iTunes und so weiter, also ich schreibe dir vor, wie du deine Daten zu speichern hast und wo du deine Daten speicherst, dass sie damit nicht leben können. Und mit dem Google Phone ist es ja nicht sehr viel anders. Und das ist das, wo ich denke, wo sie einen Edge haben.
Wobei da sehe ich ja eigentlich den eigentlichen, also ich meine die meisten Leute, die ich kenne, die sich kein iPhone geholt haben, haben sich das nicht wegen iTunes getan, sondern die haben es gesagt, weil ich keinen T-Mobile-Vertrag haben möchte. Und da ist man ja beim Palmen nun genauso gebunden an den einen großen Provider, mit dem man unter Umständen nicht möchte.
Oh ja, aber das ist aber jetzt eine amerikanische Geschichte. In Amerika ist das einfach nach wie vor der Standard. Telefone kaufst du da von deinem Provider und du hast da Providerbindung. Das ist etwas, was du so...
Naja, aber das ein Provider, das Ding exklusiv hat...
Ja, das ist normal in den USA.
Die haben Schweine. Aber das, also das wird ich für das größte Problem halten erstmal.
Gut, ich meine, auch da gibt es einen Trend Richtung UMTS. Ich denke mal, sie haben halt einfach sich einen Provider... Ich meine, mit AT&T konnten sie dann den Deal nicht machen. Dann gab es halt noch T-Mobile, die gehen mit Google. Was bleibt da noch?
Sprint.
Dafür mehr gibt es nicht. Und weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt, sagen wir mal, die Denke war oder wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall konnten sie mit Sprint dann diesen Deal machen.
Von der Subvention wären sie schon die nächsten Jahre erstmal ganz schön in dem Leben.
Ich kenne EVDO technisch nicht, aber am Ende ist es einfach nur so eine Baseband-Abstraktion.
Klar, natürlich.
Das macht dann nicht so viel aus. Das haben sie ja auch schon getan. Ich weiß nicht, so Trio und so weiter. Es ist ja nicht so, dass sie keine Knowledge haben, Telefone zu bauen.
Im Gegensatz zu Apple am Anfang.
Im Gegensatz zu Apple, genau. Und deswegen ist das nicht so das Wichtigste, dass das Ding jetzt erstmal nur EVDO ist und später ist es UMTS. Ich denke nur, vom Preis her ist es halt so eine Sache. Weil bei Apple, die konnten wirklich eine Menge Marge raushauen, weil sie einfach nur eine Hardware haben. Und das gelingt ihnen nicht. Allein schon durch diese Tastatur. Das sind so meine Fragezeichen, meine Notizen. Mehr hab ich nicht. Es gibt jetzt noch einen Punkt, und das führt jetzt aber auch auf das, was wir jetzt eben schon angesprochen haben, zurück. Nämlich mit, was hätten wir denn eigentlich ganz gerne als nächstes auf dem iPhone? Und ich hab da mal drüber nachgedacht, was mich eigentlich am meisten wurmt. Also was mich wirklich am meisten wurmt und nicht so, was man sich alles noch so vorstellen könnte, was man da so hat. Also dieses Multitasking. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das wirklich primär vermisse.
Das nervt mich wirklich ständig. Ich hab diesen Gazette, Newsreader, RSS-Reader. Und da klick ich regelmäßig mal auf das jetzt in Safari anzeigen. Und wenn Safari mir dann die Seite angezeigt hat, dann muss ich auf den Home-Button klicken. Also da geht es mir gar nicht so sehr darum, laufen jetzt zwei Applikationen, sondern wie leicht komme ich zurück zu alten Applikationen.
Das stimmt.
Das ist wirklich ätzend.
Apple fängt dir da was besseres aus. Vor allem gibt es auch Programme, die diesen State nicht so richtig speichern. Also zum Beispiel Twitterphone. Wenn du in Twitterphone arbeitest und dann fängst du an, einen Tweet zu schreiben. Und dann machst du aber Home-Button und gehst raus und gehst wieder rein. Dann kommst du halt nicht dahin. Bei Tweety geht das, bei Twitterphone geht es nicht. Also da müssen auch die Developer explizit zu beeinfragen.
Das haben sie in ihrer Keynote bei Palmets noch mal explizit erwähnt, dass sie immer stateless sind. Dass sie in jedem Zustand, dass man nie explizit speichern braucht. Und da gibt es ja beim iPhone schon einige sehr, sehr nervige Momente. Also wenn du einen neuen Termin anlegst, muss man, ich weiß nicht, wie oft man da auf fertig klicken muss, bevor man dann wirklich den abgespeichert hat. Und so einfach mal einen Termin einfügen. Und dann irgendwie, nachdem man mit der Termineingabe fertig ist, einfach sagen, alles klar, und jetzt drücke ich auf meinen Home-Button, dann wird das schon gespeichert sein. So leicht geht das nicht. Sondern da muss man mehrfach drücken. Sowas wünsche ich mir auf jeden Fall auch.
Ich kann ja ja mal unseren nächsten Mobile-Max-Podcast schon mal eintragen. Mal gucken, ob ich das nachvollziehen kann. Hier einmal sichern, dann sag ich irgendwie, wann das ist.
Sichern.
Vielleicht noch ein bisschen länger als so eine Stunde, weil wir quatschen ja mal eine Weile. So, fertig.
Ja, dann musst du mal auf fertig drücken.
Na ja, und?
Du gehst auf, also ich mach das immer so. Also am Anfang hab ich das auch so gemacht. Mittlerweile hab ich's gelernt. Ich gehe auf Anfangszeit und auf Endzeit, gehe dann auf sichern. Sichern ist für mich, das Ding ist gespeichert. Dann seh ich in diesem Dialog, wo oben noch mal fertig steht, seh ich meinen Termin, so wie ich ihn eingetragen habe, und dann denk ich mir, alles klar, ich hab grad auf sichern gedrückt, der wird jetzt gesichert sein. Und dann muss ich nochmal auf fertig drücken, damit's dann wirklich klappt.
Na gut, also ob das nun auf dem Pri so sehr viel anders sein wird, das wage ich ja stark zu bezweifeln.
Also sie haben es explizit gesagt, dass es in jedem Zustand abgespeichert wird und dass man sich nie Sorgen um seine Daten machen muss. Und das hat beim Palm auch immer sehr gut geklappt.
Was heißt das? Ja, aber das heißt ja auch nicht, dass der Termin dann schon eingetragen ist, bevor du ihn nochmal bestätigst. Das ist ja eine Designentscheidung des Programms. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass sie das nicht auch hätten so hier machen können. Aber in dem Moment, wo ich irgendwie New Date sage und ich habe drei Parameter eingegeben, will ich ja noch nicht, dass dieser Kalendereintrag auch schon existiert und dann immer wieder geändert wird.
Dann möchte ich wenigstens, dass wenn ich das nächste Mal das Kalendertrapprogramm starte, ich an diesen Bildschirm wieder ankomme.
Genau, das ist nämlich das eigentliche worum es geht. Also ob dein Programm, der State deines Programmlaufes sozusagen und die aktuellen Daten immer gesichert werden. Wobei das ist ja etwas, was eigentlich den Programm obliegt und das muss meiner Meinung nach auch dem Programm obliegen. Weil das kann das Betriebssystem nicht sicherstellen, es sei denn das Betriebssystem macht immer einen kompletten Memorydump und schreibt sozusagen den Speicher, den das Programm hat, also löscht ihn nicht. Das ist ja genau das was nicht passieren soll. Es soll ja seine Ressourcen freigeben und das muss das Programm selber machen. Das kann das Betriebssystem nicht machen. Das ist auch auf dem Prih nicht anders.
Na ja, aber ich meine, erstens könnte Apple mit besserem Beispiel selber vorangehen und ich hab ihm gerade nicht umsonst die Kalender-Applikation gewählt.
Also das ist nur wirklich etwas, wo ich nicht so drunter leide.
Also ich hab am Anfang mehrfach deswegen Termine verpasst und hab darunter gelitten.
Okay, was ist denn wenn du diesen Termin, wenn ich jetzt hier sage, ich bearbeite diesen Termin und jetzt gehe ich hier raus aus dem iCal und dann gehe ich wieder rein. Dann bin ich tatsächlich an derselben Stelle wieder.
Na ja, außer eben wenn du vorher noch nicht sicher gedrückt hast, weil dann ist er ja verworfen worden.
Das stimmt, wenn ich hier jetzt eine Änderung... Man hat ja immer das Problem mit Telefonanruf kommt rein, bricht Programm ab.
Also gerade bei solchen Applikationen, wo ich jederzeit, weil ich unterwegs bin, jederzeit rausgeschmissen werden kann, muss sowas ein bisschen besser funktionieren.
Oh, er hat das jetzt gespeichert, die Änderung, übrigens, bevor ich fertig gesagt habe. Er tut in der Tat das, was du...
Vielleicht haben sie es mittlerweile hingekriegt. Vielleicht ist es mir auch so lange nicht mehr passiert, weil sie es mittlerweile verbessert haben.
Sicher bedeutet tatsächlich sicher, mein Freund.
Ah, sehr gut, dann haben sie es jetzt.
Ja, tja, siehst du mal, sind gar nicht so scheiße.
Ist gar nicht so ein Schraubgerät von dieses iPhone.
Also ich denke, Palm ist da jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal einen PR-Stunt gelungen. Ich finde einiges gut, aber ein paar andere Sachen... Darf ich meinen Wunsch auch noch sagen, was mein größtes Problem ist? Mein größtes Problem ist, es gibt kein Dashboard. Es gibt nur diese Liste von Programmen, die du starten kannst, wenn du auf Home drückst. Und wenn es einen Feature gibt, wo ich wirklich meinem alten Nokia-Telefon hinterher traue, was eine arg überspitzte Formulierung ist, um das dann hinzuzuführen. Aber wenn es sozusagen einen Feature gibt, was ich dann doch ganz gerne rüber gerettet hätte, dann ist es die Möglichkeit, so einen Homescreen zu haben, den ich mir so weit customisieren kann, dass ich sagen kann, bestimmte Dinge sollen hier angezeigt werden können. Ich will eine Liste meiner nächsten Termine. Immer da. Ich will immer das Datum angezeigt bekommen.
Also quasi in diesem Log-Screen zum Beispiel.
Auch in dem Log-Screen. Wallpaper und so, das ist alles ganz nett. Ich will diese Informationen...
Hast du eine Antenne von eigentlich noch nicht gejailbreakt? Es gibt diese Programme für gejailbreakte iPhones.
Sogar von Katafina, glaube ich. Kann ich dir nicht sagen, ich habe Angst.
Ach, keine Panik. Jailbreak ist super.
Ist gut für mich?
Jailbreak ist gut für dich. Weißt du, was es seit gestern gibt? Weißt du, was dich zum Jailbreak vermutlich bringen wird? Es gibt seit gestern...
Ich hab's gehört.
Das kann's auch gut.
Und sie bauen es in die Tastatur rein.
Sie bauen es in die Tastatur ein. Es ist alles andere als perfekt. Apple würde es besser machen, aber man hat Copy & Paste.
Naja.
Und es funktioniert.
Copy & Paste wird kommen. Also das vermisse ich nun wirklich selten. Also das ist zwar ab und zu mal so das, was ich vielleicht auch mal ganz gerne hatte.
Aber wenn dann wirklich hausträubend, oder? Also wenn man dann in der Mail eine Adresse drinstehen hat oder irgendwo eine Telefonnummer und dann, also gerade Telefonnummern. Ich bin auf einer Webseite drauf, da steht eine Telefonnummer. Und was ich da schon geflucht habe bei der Telefonnummerneingabe, dann zwischen diesen Programmen hin und her zu wechseln, wie gerade erwähnt, es gibt ja auch keine einfache Switching-Funktion. Also Copy & Paste.
Also bei dem Switching, da gebe ich dir absolut recht. Ich hätte ganz gerne halt noch so eine Dashboard-Funktionalität. Ich möchte also einfach einen Screen haben, auf dem mir halt, also Dashboard wirklich im einlichen Sinne, so eine Instrumententafel. Ich möchte die wichtigsten Informationen von meinen Programmen hätte ich gerne beisammen. Und ist es nicht sogar so, dass das für... Oh Gott, war das jetzt auch Android? Wer hat denn das? Oder was ist das neue Nokia-Telefon sogar, wo sie irgendwie diesen ganzen Facebook-Klimbim und so weiter auch in dem Homescreen einbauen konnten? Ich glaube, das war dieses komische Nokia, was glaube ich auf Windows Mobile oder dann doch wieder sind wir in Brasilien? Ich weiß es nicht. Wie auch immer. Also da muss auf jeden Fall was passieren. Das kann einfach nicht sein, dass man immer nur so auf seine Programme schaut. Insbesondere wenn man so viel installiert hat wie ich. Ich habe jetzt hier irgendwie 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 Seiten voll mit Programm. Definitiv mehr als man normalerweise braucht. Also 3, 4. Können es schon mal werden. Und ich finde es einfach anstrengend. Also erstens ist das Sortieren.
Das Sortieren ist total scheiße.
Das Kategorisieren, das ist einfach irgendwie unwürdig. Und das geht nicht. Da muss ich definitiv noch was verbessern. Das ist mein Verdikt zum Thema Pre.
Hoffen wir, dass sich Apple möglichst viel von Pre abguckt. Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich was es...
Jetzt wird es zumindest gerade ganz spannend, ob unser Podcast sich schon lang genug verzögert hat und lang genug nach hinten geschoben wird. Ob wir sozusagen noch die Möglichkeit haben, die First-Quarter-Results mitzubekommen.
Live kommentieren, das wird ein Spaß.
Da müssten wir aber jetzt noch zwei Stunden weitermachen. Das wird uns keiner verzeihen. Also, wenn wir das Thema Geld verdienen, nicht in diesen Podcast reinkriegen. Tja, was steht denn überhaupt an?
Willkommen beim Mobile Palm Podcast.
Ja, Mobile Palm. Heute geht es eigentlich nur darum.
Das ist zwar ein bisschen ein Notlücken-Thema, aber wie irgendjemand in den Kommentaren uns darauf hingewiesen hat, wird der Macintosh am 24. also am Samstag, 25 Jahre alt. Also vor 25 Jahren 1984 sei er vorgestellt worden. Und die Frage war, was wird an neuen Produkten kommen? Ich glaube, die können wir relativ schnell beantworten mit absolut gar nichts. Oder? Meinst du, dass am 25. Geburtstag das Max irgendwas kommen wird?
Ich glaube nicht.
So was wie ein 20s-Anniversary-Macintosh wird es nicht mehr geben. Wobei es auch eine schicke Kiste war.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das für sie wirklich wichtig ist.
Also das...
Weißt du, also das ist... Da könnten sie jetzt einen Aufhänger haben, aber...
Werden sie nicht nutzen.
Ich weiß nicht, ich rechne nicht damit.
Ich rechne auch nicht damit.
Aber ich rechne damit, ich wäre schon ganz froh, wenn sie mir endlich mal einen neuen Mac Mini besorgen würden.
Der könnte langsam wirklich mal ruhig kommen.
Der könnte jetzt wirklich mal kommen und...
Aber das ist eine gute Gelegenheit, mal wieder auf dieses Folklore Radio Podcast hinzuweisen. Und zwar, es gibt ja dieses Andy Herzfeld, einer der ursprünglichen Mac-Entwickler. Hat ja irgendwann mal vor ein paar Jahren ein Buch geschrieben und hat dafür die Webseite folklore.org gegründet, wo er sehr viele Artikel, die er für dieses Buch geschrieben hat, da quasi einfach mal reingestellt hat. Wie kann man das lesen? Das liest sich teilweise recht unterhaltsam. Und jetzt weiß ich natürlich den Namen von dem entsprechenden Macher nicht. Und eine andere Person hat dann den Folklore Radio Podcast daraus gemacht, weil das steht alles unter Creative Commons und das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Und da gibt es einen wirklich sehr, sehr unterhaltsamen, netten Podcast Folklore Radio, wie oft heißt es jetzt gesagt, oft genug. Dieser Folklore Radio Podcast war eine ganze Zeit lang eingeschlafen und ist jetzt seit kurz vor Weihnachten wieder aktiv mit vielen, vielen neuen Podcast-Folgen. Und ich habe mir auf dem Weg hierher ein paar angehört. Das macht echt Spaß.
Mackintosh Folklore Radio, ich schlage sie gerade mal nach. Schön mit alten Mackintosh-Icon.
Das hat auch so...
Derrick Warren macht das.
Derrick Warren. Und wenn man den startet, ich weiß nicht, ob du den jetzt kurz anspielen kannst, dann hat man auch so ein Startgeräusch vom Mack und wie er das Kettenlaufwerk so hochfährt.
Soll ich das mal tun? Man muss sich den aber erstmal runterladen.
Die sind immer auch relativ kurz im Gegensatz zu uns. Das ist quasi der Reserv für Mobile Next. Das ist, dass man danach noch mal so sechs, sieben Minuten lang...
Kurz-Podcaster.
Das ist doch Feigheit vor dem Feind.
Der macht das einfach nicht live, der liest einfach nur einen Text vor, der hat eine gewisse Länge. Verstehst du, das ist nicht pro Folge ein Buch.
Wenn ich zwei Stunden hintereinander podcasten kann, ist auch kein richtiger Podcaster. Oh weia, ich hab hier schon so viele Podcasts in meiner Liste, das geht irgendwie gar nicht. Vor allem, ich hab mir diese komischen iPhone-Ringtons, die du das letzte Mal erwähnt hast, die hab ich mir ja mal runtergeladen. Da war ja nicht sehr viel Lustiges dabei.
Nee, lustig waren die nicht, oder? Die waren ja auch eher für Business-Serious-Stuff.
Geht so.
Geht so?
Ich fand nur ganz wenige gut. Ich kann mal einen anspielen hier.
Mach mal.
Den.
Was sind das die, die ich gesagt hab?
Das ist dieser MacMost-Iphone-Ringtons.
Hohoho.
Nee, ich meinte was anderes.
Echt?
Ich meinte was anderes, ja.
Wirklich?
Ja, das hat auch Geld gekostet.
Ach so, wirklich?
Das war so.
Okay, dann hab ich vielleicht was anderes gefunden. Die haben hier so ein paar freie Sachen. Naja, also ich gehöre auch nicht zu den Leuten, die alle zwei Tage ihren Rington irgendwie ausmachen.
Ich wechsle alle 20 Jahre meinen Screen-Rington.
Ich dachte, da wäre vielleicht irgendwie was Nettes dabei. Ich hab hier noch so einen Leoparden irgendwie. Den kann ich auch nochmal mit reinschmeißen.
Ganz großartig.
Vielleicht ist das schon ein Schneeleopard.
Guck mal, wie der klingt. Okay, dem gibt's...
Also am Schluss, das war schon das neue Multicore-Geräusch.
Das Multicore-Geräusch?
Ja, das gibt dann dein OS von sich, wenn irgendwie mehrere Chores gleichzeitig laufen.
Abbrennen. Überhitzen.
Das wird albern.
Und was ich mir noch angeguckt habe...
Okay, aber ich sollte ja mal diese Macintosh von Flore... Muss ich jetzt die allererste Ausgabe? Nein, das ist einfach nur die ersten 5 Sekunden überhaupt. Dann spiele ich das mal an, beziehungsweise ich versuche das anzuspielen. Mal gucken...
So lange kann ich noch erzählen. Außerdem kommen jetzt zum 25. noch zwei Filme raus. Der eine heißt Mac Hats. Der taucht da auch in den Kommentaren auf. Das stimmt. Das geht so um Mac Fanboys und...
Den hast du aber noch nicht gesehen.
Den hab ich nicht gesehen. Was ich aber gesehen habe ist Welcome to Macintosh. Und das ist echt ein schöner Film. Das ist...
Gibt's den im Piratenkino?
Den gibt's... Ich hätt ihn ja gerne gekauft, aber gab's leider auf der Webseite nichts digitalen Kauf, dass man sagt, ich zahl dir 20 Dollar und lad mir den runter.
Ja, gibt's hier auf Mininova ein Link irgendwie 79 Seeder.
Und das ist echt. Da sind auch mit Guy Kawasaki zum Beispiel und diversen anderen Apple-Entwicklern und Mac-Entwicklern der ersten Stunde diverse Interviews gemacht. Und es ist eine großartige, unterhaltsame Dokumentation. Ich weiß leider nicht mehr, wie er heißt. Es ist auch der Entwickler des Original, des bis heute noch aktuellen Start-up-Sounds des Macs. Wie heißt denn der? Leider so ein Musiker, der auch den Sound-Manager geschrieben hat von Mac und der dann irgendwann mal diesen Start-up-Sound gemacht hat. Und so die ganzen Geschichten und was da alles im Hintergrund passiert ist. Und also am Sonnabend, wenn ihr abends nichts besseres vor habt, dann stellt eine Kerze auf euren alten Mac Plus und guckt euch dazu den... Jim Reeks? Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der heißt.
Der hat den Macintosh Start-up-Sound gemacht.
Na es gibt ja mehrere. Das ist Susumi, oder?
Ich hab mal bei Susumi nachgeschlagen, weil da wusste ich, dass ich schnell zu diesem Thema komme.
Das kann sein. Kannst du mal den Namen anklicken und dann einfach, wenn ich ein Bild von ihm sehe, dann weiß ich es. Da ist aber kein Bild von ihm. Auf jeden Fall hat er einen sehr eigenen Humor. Der kann sehr unterhaltsam erzählen.
Naja, das können die Amerikaner ja immer. Das muss man nie erlassen.
Und Guy Kawasaki hat, der offizieller Macintosh Evangelist war, der erste glaube ich sogar, also dessen Job ist, war Entwickler davon zu überzeugen, noch für diesen neuen Macintosh zu entwickeln. Was wohl auch nicht so ganz trivial war am Anfang. Erzählt ein paar Geschichten und guckt euch das an.
Gut, ich kann ja mal hier kurz diesen Folklore-Podcast anspielen.
Genau.
Mit Floppy.
Ist das nicht eine Erinnerung?
So was brauchen wir auch.
Das ist super, oder?
Und jetzt mit Techno. In Amerika. Das war reichen?
Ja, das war cool. Den Rest könnt ihr euch selber anschauen. Ja, das ist...
Oder wir könnten ja auch so ein PC-Start-up machen. Weißt du, wie so ein PC...
Nee, wir machen dieses... Wenn er früher abgestürzt ist, wenn der Ramp kaputt war. Da gab es verschiedene. Es gab sogar immer traurig klingende Moll-Akkorde oder so was, die aber unterschiedliche Melodien haben, automatisch generiert worden. Man konnte anhand des Sounds rauskriegen, was kaputt ist. Ich hatte sogar mal ein Programm, mit dem man die alle erzeugen und dann vergleichen. Und dann wusste man, ob deine Grafikkarte im Arsch ist.
Das kannst du ja mal ausgraben.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich das noch irgendwo auftreiben kann. Und es gab mal eine Zeit lang bei Pornos...
Ich finde auch so PC Start-ups auch geil. Wie man so ankommt, schaltest du an und so......dreee......erstmal so diese Ram durchzählen.
Man hört, wie er den Anhaltsspeicher hochzählt, oder? Wie hieß denn das Programm? Mac Tracker? Es gibt ein Programm, da kann man sich alle Macs angucken, die es so jemals gab, mit technischen Daten. Ich weiß leider nicht mehr, wie es heißt. Und die haben auch eine Sammlung von allen Start-up-Sounds und Crash-Sounds dabei.
Das wird ja heute voll die Folklore-Ausgabe hier.
Ja, hallo, das war jetzt der Versuch, da wir sonst außerhalb haben keine Themen haben, das wäre so ein bisschen so dem Zeitgeist anzupassen.
Unsere Hörer freuen sich auch mal über eine kurze Ausgabe. Na selbstverständlich.
Und wir sind ja...
Ich hab immer wieder so Leute, die der Meinung sind so, ich hab mir die letzte Folge angehört, aber ihr habt ja wohl eine Meise drei Stunden.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt auch nicht drei Stunden.
Warum ist es aber trotzdem angehört?
Wer hat jetzt die Meise?
Also...
Naja, wir können nicht anders. Ja. Lass mal kurz schauen. Wir haben jetzt...
Irgendjemand meinte noch, wir sollten auf die anderen Kommentare eingeben.
Ja, das wollten wir auch. Das machen wir nämlich jetzt auch. Also wir haben nicht wirklich... Also, dass wir noch erwähnen können, es gibt ein neues MacBook. Haben wir da schon mal was zugesagt?
Wir haben gar nichts zugesagt. Hey, schicken Sie mal ein MacBook!
Hat mich ein bisschen überrascht, aber dann auch wieder nicht. Weil... also auf der einen... Weil am Anfang weiß ich nicht so richtig, wie lange diese Phase mit billiges MacBook dauern sollte offensichtlich.
Also Sie haben das weiße MacBook, das was eigentlich so aussah wie das unglückliche Steve Kind. Was nur noch da ist, weil...
Steve Kind.
Ich glaube, wir sollten die mit der Mateflasche erschlagen. Ja, und so, ja, wir wollten auch irgendwas, was unter 1000 Dollar ist.
Also Sie haben da jetzt auf jeden Fall einen neuen Professor reingehauen, glaube ich.
Oder ist das noch der alte? Ich glaube, ein bisschen schnellerer Prozessor. Und 2 Gigahertz. Aber die 9400er Grafikkarte von Nvidia. Also den gleichen Chipslides, das gleiche Motherboard, was auch das nächste größere MacBook hat.
Aber ohne Displayport.
Aber dafür mit Firewire.
Genau, immer noch. Aber ohne S-Video. Und ohne Composite-Video. Weil das nämlich dieser Stein nicht mehr macht.
Genau, aber Firewire kann offensichtlich.
Das haben sie einfach nicht rausgenommen. Das ist ja noch ein Mainboard, das ist ja separat. Das hat ja mit der Grafikkarte nichts zu tun. Also eigentlich haben sie nur die Grafikkarte getauscht. Na gut, Chipsatz, das ist halt ein eigener Stein.
Warte mal, kommt da nicht mehr von Nvidia?
Ja, aber Firewire, das ist ja genau das Ding. Das wird ja in diesem PC-Markt nicht gebaut. Das kommt nicht rein in diese Chipsätze, weil das ist halt einfach zu esoterisch. Und deswegen ist es ja auch so teuer, um das einzubauen. Deswegen haben sie das jetzt eben auch sein gelassen in der MacBook-Reihe, weil sie ja meinen sind.
Aber das ist ausgerechnet der billigste MacBook noch vorhanden. Das schrie ich doch ein bisschen gegen, das kann teuer sein, oder?
Na ja, das ist halt... Das Gerät können sie halt einfach für diesen Preis verkaufen. Woran es liegt, ich denke mal, das ist vor allem das Gehäuse, was die einer MacBooks derzeit noch so pricier macht. Vielleicht zahlen sie auch mehr für ihre Displays oder fürs Glas oder I don't know.
Ich würde auch vermuten, dass das Gehäuse ist.
Man weiß es nicht.
Der Chat korrigiert mich gerade. Eigentlich noch nicht besonders erfolgreich. Die sagen nur, ich hab Unrecht.
Womit?
Weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich damit, dass in den Chipsets kein Firewire drin ist. Es gibt natürlich vielleicht Chipsets, die das haben, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die Chipsetze...
Nee, aber ist da nicht...
Achso, er meint, dass es im Alu nicht... Ja, ja, naja, was heißt es? Sie haben beschlossen, dass sie es nicht mehr reinbauen müssen, also konnten sie den Platz für was anderes nutzen. Da kann man jetzt lange drüber philosophieren, warum Firewire...
Na, was hat sich mehr geändert als die Grafikkarte? Ich meine, der Rahmen hat sich glaube ich auch geändert, ist jetzt auch der schnellere ein bisschen und so was.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, sie halten dieses Gerät nach wie vor aufrechts, weil sie es wohl als wichtig erachten, noch billig anzubieten. Vielleicht ist es für sie auch wichtig, noch Firewire in diesem Niedrigpreissegment anzubieten. Das weiß ich nicht. Da werden sich die Musiker auf jeden Fall freuen, weil jetzt kriegen sie zumindest eine schnelle Grafikkarte. Ich muss mir ehrlich gesagt, bleibt mal überlegen, ob das nicht ein Thema wäre. Für mich ist eigentlich entscheidend, ob das Ding dadurch kälter läuft als das aktuelle Teil. Weil das könnte schon eine ganze Menge Last nehmen von dem Prozessor. Weil du hast im Augenblick das Problem, der ist einfach zu laut. Der ist immer an. Aber mein OS ist auch durch. Ich hatte jetzt verschiedene Freezes und so weiter. Ich muss dieses Ding neu installieren. Ich weiß bloß, dass mich das ein ganzes Wochenende kosten wird, bis ich wirklich from scratch mal wieder alles aufgesetzt habe. Also ich meine so mit allen. Mit allen Präferenzen geklärt und so weiter. Wollen wir noch mal auf ein paar Kommentare eingehen?
Können wir machen. Wir sind übrigens gerade nicht live, weil ich glaube dein Internet ist fucked. Kann das sein?
Das kann man nie ausschließen. Aber wir können ja trotzdem schon mal.
Dann können wir ja so lange über Apple Script reden, wie der Apple Script nicht zuhören kann.
Nein, wir machen ja hier auch einen Podcast und nicht für live. Live ist immer ganz nett, wenn es nebenbei läuft. Aber das ist nicht so wichtig. Also was... Wieso nimmst du jetzt meine...
Achso, ich dachte du guckst jetzt so lange wie wir... Ah, jetzt sind wir auch wieder auf dem Air.
Gab's mal wieder ein Reconnect oder was?
Ich hab jetzt einfach noch mal auf Stop und Start. Egal. Hast du mal was mit Apple Script gemacht?
Apple Script? Ich soll mich zu Apple Script äußern?
Das wird sogar blutig. Das ist furchtbar, oder?
Ich hasse Apple Script.
Es ist scheiße dokumentiert.
Auch das. Es ist auch scheiße dokumentiert, aber es ist auch eine Schnapsidee gewesen. Ich lobe ihren Mut, den sie mal gehabt haben, als sie Apple Script mal eingeführt haben. Und an sich ist das auch eine tolle Idee, ein systemübergreifendes Framework zu haben, wo Programme mit Introspection ihr Dictionary File bieten können und sagen, was sie alles an tollen Events und internen Datenstrukturen machen. In der Theorie ganz großartig. Ja, und auch die Allgemeinerung, und dass man da mit einer einheitlichen Sprache rüber kann. Alles gar keine schlechte Idee. Allerdings, Apple Script krank an zwei Sachen. Das erste ist, dass sie von Anfang an nie wirklich es geschafft haben, durch die Bank mal alle Systemssoftware auch wirklich Apple Script-fähig zu machen. Beziehungsweise, wenn ein Programm das konnte, nie alle Features wirklich exposed waren. Sondern es war immer nur irgendwas. Und ich hab immer so eine Phase jetzt über zehn Jahre, wo ich dann immer so alle zwei Jahre mir denke so, ach, jetzt gibt's der Apple Script mal wieder eine Chance. Und dann guck ich halt irgendwie nach, und dann konnte wieder der Finder, oder irgendwie welches Programm, irgend sowas ganz einfaches nicht. Und damit war das dann für mich wieder rausgekickt. Das zweite Problem, und das wiegt meiner Meinung nach noch schwerer, ist die Syntax von Apple Script ist wirklich zum Heulen. Und das liegt an mehreren Sachen. Erstens hatten sie irgendwie in so einem Anfall von Wahn, waren sie der Meinung, sie müssten jetzt auch noch Programmiersprachen so für Dreijährige erschließbar machen, oder für Endjunge. Und Wahn der Auffassung, dass es doch eine tolle Idee ist, dass man die Syntax so macht, dass man sie wie Englisch schreibt.
So halbwegs.
Genau. Gepaart mit der Idee, das haben sie nie umgesetzt, aber das hat sozusagen immer noch ihre Spuren, dass man dieselbe Sache auch in einer anderen Sprache als Englisch machen könnte. Theoretisch hätte das sozusagen auch ein französisches und deutsches Applescript so. Ich glaube, es gab sogar im OO die 5 in die variabere Show.
Hast du jemals Visual Basic für Windows geschrieben?
Nein.
Wenn, dann sonst?
Doch, plus da ist das so.
Ja, natürlich.
Ist nicht dein Ernst.
Natürlich. Deutsch? Ich weiß nicht, ob es VBA war oder diese Excel-Eingriffssprache.
Egal, das will ich gar nicht wissen. Das ist mir egal. Da macht die Augen zu, la la la. Was ist allerdings, was ist allerdings, also da war die, also lasst mich kurz den Gedanken zu Ende bringen, das Problem ist, du kannst halt dasselbe in Apple-Script in 10 verschiedenen Varianten schreiben. Mit anderen Worten, du kannst von anderem Code nicht lernen, weil du einfach jeden Scheiß, wie sowas wie, Weise einer Variable, den Wert 5 zu, kannst du irgendwie in 10 verschiedenen Varianten schreiben und es wird dann eben auch in 10 verschiedenen Varianten geschrieben. Das zweite oder mittlerweile dritte große Problem ist diese Dynamik. Du hast halt irgendwie so ein Apple-Script und das bezieht sich auf irgendein Programm. Tell Application Frame Maker to open the document and put the fifth Absatz of the front window in the tralalala and then put it into the bin and then close the door. So, dann speicherst du dieses Script ab, öffnest das auf einem anderen Computer und dort ist kein Frame Maker installiert und dann wird es einfach, dann kommt es hoch mit, wo ist Frame Maker?
Und ansonsten, er kann dir nicht mal den Quellcode anzeigen, wenn er das Problem nicht hat.
Genau, es ist vollkommen bekloppt. Das heißt, es gibt einfach keine normalisierte Offline-Form von Code. Du kannst es irgendwie auch nicht ordentlich wiedergeben und es ist einfach, es ist Fail. Für mich, also Applescript ist für mich der totale Fail und sie müssen es töten. Sie haben eigentlich nur eine Chance, sie müssen eigentlich ihr Systemscripting auf Python umstellen. Ich sehe da keine andere Wahl.
Weißt du, was lustig ist? Ich könnte dir quasi in allem zustimmen, außer sich immer minimal anders, also ich würde sagen, es ist ein totaler Fail, aber aus anderen Gründen als du.
Welche denn?
Also ich finde es erstmal, es war ja so ein bisschen an Hyper Talk angelehnt und Hyper Talk war ich ein Big-Fan von. Das war ein Hyper Talk? Das war ein Hyper Talk, dieses On-Stuff und sowas, On-Mouse-Up, so ein bisschen dieses Event-basierte. Diese Event-Geschichte, ja okay. Ganz minimal erinnert das an Hyper Talk und Hyper Talk war ja auch schon der Versuch so, wir machen das mal so ein bisschen an der englischen Sprache dran. Aber das war glaube ich von Bill Ektensen, Hyper Card, großartiges Tool, habe ich Programmieren mit gelernt.
Hyper Card ist eine tolle Idee. Das Konzept hat ja auch Erfolg gehabt. Das heißt World Wide Web.
Bill Ektensen hat sich dieses Hyper Card ausgedacht, hat das mal eben mit ein paar Kumpels zurechtgeschrieben und hat was Großartiges geschaffen und irgendwann in den dunklen Apple-Zeiten, System 7.1 oder sowas, kommt dann Apple auf die Idee, wir setzen mal eine ganz große Abteilung dran und entwickeln mal sowas wie Applescript und machen das so ein bisschen wie das großartige, erfolgreiche Hyper Card. Und vergessen dabei alles, und zwar insbesondere Apple. Fucking hell, ihr wart immer bekannt fürs User-Interface und ihr habt dieses Applescript gemacht, wo man wirklich Probleme hat, einen dämlichen Dialog anzuzeigen. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, also es gibt bis heute, mittlerweile gibt es sie glaube ich, bei Xcode kann man ja auch in Applescript programmieren.
Ja, ja, das hat sich schon verbessert, so ist es ja nicht.
Aber es ist nie wirklich angekommen, dann diese Dictionaries, die man dann aufmachen kann. Also man kann mit dem Script-Editor, wenn man sich dann die entsprechenden Befehle anzeigen lässt, das ist immer nur kryptisch. Ihr habt niemals erst geschafft, dass irgendjemand, dass ihr mal eine vernünftige Dokumentation habt, und zwar nicht nur in Form einer Reihenreferenz, welche Befehle gibt es, sondern dass sie mal vernünftig gegliedert sind, dass irgendwie ein Programmierer, das eine Dokumentation irgendwo reinschmeißen kann, die mir weiterhilft. Ich muss mich jedes Mal stundenlang durch dieses Dictionary durchwickeln. Und zum dritten habe ich bis heute keinerlei Quellen gefunden, wie die Syntax von Apple Script überhaupt im Detail funktioniert. Ich hab mir das im Laufe der Zeit so mit Set, Variablen, Namen, Tu irgendwas und so was.
Ne läuft nur ein kalter Schaum. Das kann man auch alles nicht erklären.
Aber ich glaube, ich weiß bis heute nicht, welche Loopform es gibt in Apple Script.
Apple Script ist wirklich tot. Und ich glaube auch nicht daran, dass sie es mit welchen Klimmzügen auch immer irgendwie reaktivieren können. Das ist einfach unseriöse Scheiße. Sie sollen einen Weg finden, wie diese Objektmodelle, die sie ja da quasi beschreiben. Dass es scriptfähig ist, das ist ja die eigene Eigenschaft. Und das ist eine tolle Sache. Dass Programme in der Lage sind, in objektorientierter Manier interne Funktionsweisen nach außen mit einem einheitlich ansprechbaren Interface zu präsentieren, das ist super. Aber nutzen sollte man das nicht mit Apple Scripts, sondern man sollte da irgendwie was Normales nehmen. Und meines Wissens geht das auch mit Python. Wobei, Moment, nicht meines Wissens, sondern meiner Ahnung gemäß, gibt es auch Möglichkeiten, das mit Python zu nutzen. Das weiß ich jetzt aber gerade nicht genau. Da sei ich auch für Hints und Tipps in den Kommentaren sehr dankbar.
Das ist ja eigentlich das Lustige. Also der Grund, warum man Apple Scripts ja immer nur an dem Rechner an Wesentlichen aufmachen kann, an dem man sie geschrieben hat, ist ja der Gedanke, dass man sie an jedem beliebigen Rechner aufmachen sollte. Weil man kann so einen kompilierten Skript die Syntax unterm Arsch weg austauschen. Also das, was du meintest, dass sie sich ursprünglich mal gedacht haben, dass es da mehrere Sprachen für gibt, was kompletter Bullshit ist. Ich glaube, das haben sie auch mal geschafft bis Spanisch. In Spanisch gab es das auch für die Mexikaner. Und dann konnten man sich...
Beziehungsweise für die Spanisch sprechenden US.
Genau. Und die konnten sich dann ihre Apple Skripte auch in Spanisch angucken. Aber es gab auch mal eine Zeit lang so Open Source Ansätze, dass man da in JavaScript das Ganze formulieren kann. Was das Ganze gleich etwas hübscher aussehen lässt. Aber es ist immer noch viel zu langsam und viel zu... und der Editor ist total scheiße und ich mag Apple Skript auch wirklich nicht. Apple Events gibt es ja auch nach wie vor. Also Apple Skript basiert ja auf Apple Events. Nämlich die Kommunikationssprache, mit der viele Apple Programme auch mit System 7 damals untereinander kommunizieren sollten. Darauf basiert ja auch dieses Publish und Subscribe, worüber wir auch schon gesprochen haben. Und das gibt es ja nach wie vor. Und das kann ja theoretisch, können das ja sehr viele abgreifen. Das kann natürlich Python sein. Aber ich nehme mal an, dass Apple sich da von dem, was ich sehe, eher für Ruby oder für JavaScript entscheiden würde.
Was für Scripting?
Genau. Also Ruby gibt es ja an einigen Punkten schon. Ruby wird ja mittlerweile mit einem Betriebssystem mitgeliefert, Python auch. Aber in Xcode kann man ja wirklich, da sind ja auch ein paar schöne Ruby Beispiele dabei, mit denen man...
Also Ruby ist ein heißer Kandidat, die zweite offiziell unterstützte Programmiersprache zu werden, um Macintosh-Applikate zu bringen.
So ein richtiger Native Citizen.
Scripting allerdings ist nochmal ein anderer Vogel. Und Python ist eine Sprache, die explizit dafür mal gemacht wurde. Also es war von Anfang an die Intention, von Python embeddable zu sein und Scripting zu fördern.
So.
Das ist mittlerweile alles sehr viel weiter und man kann mit Python ja auch Macintosh Anwendungen machen, auch wenn dieses Objektmodell von Apple halt nicht so in dem Maße unterstützt wird, wie sie das jetzt mit diesem MacRuby Projekt machen. Aber es gibt da schon verschiedene Bridges und Apple-Events ansprechen ist ja auch nochmal eine ganz andere Geschichte als das komplette Framework zu verwenden. Und von daher spricht da nichts gegen. Ich meine, das dann auch noch in Ruby zu machen, gut, ist wahrscheinlich auch kein großes Problem. Aber da weiß ich es jetzt grad nicht, wie es jetzt wirklich aussieht und ich weiß auch jetzt nicht, wo die technischen Schwierigkeiten sind, diese Apple-Events da zu übernehmen. Das ist im Wesentlichen eine Frage der Introspection, die dort nötig ist und die Datenmodelle müssen halt abgebildet werden. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall Apple muss da irgendwas tun und mit diesem Apple-Script alleine wird das nichts. Auch dieser Automator hat die Situation nicht wirklich verbessert. Ich meine, hast du mit diesem Automator mal irgendwas hingekriegt?
Ja.
Was denn?
Mit Automator hab ich genau einen Prozess hingekriegt und der funktioniert tatsächlich flawless. Das ist, muss ich jetzt ein bisschen ausdehnen, das ist ein Prozess mit dem... Was einfach? Also ich hab mal für eine Firma, das ist auf der Webseite releasethefreaks.com. Das ist so ein Shop, wo man so kleine Toys kaufen kann. Und da gibt's so eine 360 Grad Ansicht von diesen Toys, also so kleine Plüschfiguren, die es in hippen Designer-Shops gibt. Dann gibt's so eine schicke 360 Grad Ansicht, die hab ich damals in Flash gemacht. Und da hab ich mit einem Fotografen zusammengesessen, wie kriegt man die 360 Grad Ansichten rein? Weil wir hatten keine 3D-Modelle von diesen ganzen Püppchen, also mussten die fotografiert werden. Und das läuft im Endeffekt so, da sitzt eine arme Praktikantin in einem Raum, der immer gleich beleuchtet ist, darum ist ja komplett abgedunkelt. Und ihr sitzt dann da und hat ein Blitzlicht, was automatisch den ganzen Raum ausleuchtet. Und direkt an der Kamera hängt ein USB-Kabel dran. Man braucht nämlich die Kamera nicht auszuschalten, um das auszulesen. Und dann macht die nichts weiter als einen Automator-Skript zu starten. Und das macht dann, das lädt die runter, die Bilder von der Kamera, dreht die, weil die Kamera hoch kann, steht, geht irgendwie über dreieinhalb Farbfilter einmal drüber, dass die perfekten Einstellungen da sind, packt die alle in einen Ordner, generiert ein Preview.
Welche Programme bringst du denn da zum Einsatz? Weil das ist ja letztlich entscheidend, um einen Automator Automator oder Applescript zum Einsatz zu bringen. Brauchen wir ja Programme, die auch scriptigen.
Nee, es gibt Plugins. Es gibt Plugins dafür.
Für was?
Das kann man im Wesentlichen mit den Grundfunktionen, die dafür da sind.
Wo?
In Automator. Also Automator kann Dateien umbenennen.
Ohne jetzt exquisit den Finder anzusprechen?
Automator kann von ganz alleine Bilder drehen, was wir brauchten. Also ein paar Grundfunktionen kann Automator von sich aus.
Wo er sozusagen das OS benutzt und nicht ein Programm.
Genau. Und es war sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schwer. Also es heißt jetzt nicht, dass ich Automator deswegen liebe oder auch nur schätzen würde, sondern ich hasse es genauso abgrundtief wie du. Aber genau diesen einen Arbeitsprozess haben wir damals mit viel Biegen und Brechen in Automator hinbekommen. Und er funktioniert großartig. Also der letzte Prozess war dann irgendwie, dass er dann das Ganze noch auf ein File Sharing Volume kopiert, damit es dann gleich ins CMS eingebunden wird.
Also da, auf der Basis, könnte ich mir mit Automator und sagen wir mal, dass es jetzt nicht so sehr von Programmen abhängig ist, sondern dass wirklich eine Systemfunktionalität, also das, was sozusagen die OS-Frameworks können, dass das gut abstrahiert wird und dass man das mit so einem Drag- und Dropinterface, was ja Automator ist, automatisiert bekommt. Das finde ich einen unterstützenswürdigen Ansatz. Nur Applescript als Programmiersprache finde ich irgendwie es fehl.
Ja und Automator kann auch, solange da du nicht so reine Batch-Sachen hast, wo oben kommt es rein und unten fällt es wieder raus. Du kannst keine Parameter übergeben, du kannst nichts machen, was du mit jeder halbwegs brauchbaren Programmiersprache machen kannst. Außer eben Array of Files oder weiß der Teufel was. Und das ist irgendwie...
Na gut, ich meine es geht ihnen auch darum, Daily-Tasks zu machen, mit was halt schwierig werde, wenn man es eben von Hand macht.
Ja, aber wie du schon richtig sagtest, welchen Prozess kann man mit Automator da vernünftig auf die Reihe kriegen?
Ja, ich hab immer das Problem, dass wenn ich mal geguckt habe und dass einfach die konkrete Funktionalität so nicht da war.
Achso, und natürlich Bilder von der Kamera runterladen. Das konnte das ganze Ding auch. Das war nämlich der eigentliche Vorteil. Das war nämlich so eine Profikamera, die nicht das Ganze dann gemountet hat als Volume auf dem Desktop, die Platte, sondern die, wo man dann mit diesem Image-Importierprogramm, was dabei ist, die Sachen runterladen musste. Und das konnte Automator auch. Also Automator konnte alles, was wir brauchten, durch Zufall. Ich hab anfangs nicht damit gerechnet, ich hab ihm die Chance gegeben, es hat auf Anip funktioniert, und daraufhin hab ich gesagt, brauche ich mir keine Sorgen darum zu machen.
Wollen wir jetzt mal das Ende einleiten und mal ein wenig zumindest, also ihr habt ja wirklich, ich finde das ja super, also es gab unglaublich viel Response, mehr als ich jetzt leider in den letzten zwei Wochen war zu verarbeiten. Ein Großteil zu ZFS und so, und wenn wir Denis wieder von der Straße gekratzt haben, dann werden wir dieses Thema hier auch nochmal aufgreifen. Ich gehe jetzt mal hier kurz durch die Anmerkungen, die jetzt hier zu unserer Ankündigung der Live-Sendung kamen. Da sind jetzt auch ein paar Sachen nochmal zu dem Thema ZFS, die lasse ich jetzt schon mal bewusst aus, weil das wäre jetzt eh nur ein halbes Gewäsch. So, was steht denn hier? Hier findet jetzt jemand spannend, mehr über unsere Home-Entertainment-Lösungen zu erfahren. Ich kann dir sagen, das ist nicht spannend, weil meine Home-Entertainment-Lösung ist langweilig. Besteht im Wesentlichen aus diesem Mini, der an einem Fernseher angeschlossen ist. Das ist irgendwie das ganze Home-Entertainment. Also sehr viel mehr habe ich da nicht.
Ich habe eine gehackte Xbox mit XBMC drauf im Augenblick noch, was jetzt irgendwo mal ersetzt werden sollte. Und einen kleinen Server mit 23 GB Platten insgesamt.
Was für ein Server?
Ach, irgendein alter Pensionfir, ganz furchtbares Teil.
Was surft der?
SMB, SSH und im Wesentlichen läuft da das übliche BitTorrent drauf.
Für die Linux-Distribution.
Genau, die brauche ich alle 5 Wochen. Und natürlich immer den ganzen Chaos vom Kongress die ganzen Videos runterzuladen. Und selber auch zu seeden.
Dann unsere Meinung zu Android, dem G1 und dem Mobile. Das haben wir jetzt so eingestreut. Also den Thema über Tarifen im Wesentlichen. Das ist unsere Meinung, dass wir nicht verstanden haben, was sie uns sagen wollen. Alles zu kompliziert, das ist meine Aussage dazu. Aber vielleicht bin ich auch nur selber zu blöd. Dann wird hier gebeten, dass ich dich lauter abmischen soll. Ich glaube, das wird mir heute gelungen sein. Dann die Anti-Reflektionsbeschichtung. Sei eine Klebefolie. Nein, das ist sie nicht. Das ist einfach ein anderes Screencover. Da ist ja auch eine andere Umrahmung drin. Man lässt halt den Glas-Overlay weg. Dann sieht es im Wesentlichen so aus, wie es früher auch aussah. Ich finde, es sieht ein bisschen doof aus. Ich habe es nicht live gesehen. Ich habe es nicht live gesehen.
Aber es gibt von irgendeinem Anbieter, der hat sich diese Lücke zu eigen gemacht. Fürs MacBook Pro wechseln die das Display aus. Ich glaube, es kostet ein 100 Dollar. Geht overnight in Amerika nur bisher.
Meist für das 15 Zoller.
Genau, und machen dann auch ein Glossy-Display drauf.
Wer's braucht? Ich meine ja immer noch, dass es nicht so viele sind.
Also beim MacBook Pro habe ich auch schon gesehen, aber beim MacBook mit Glasfront davor, also bei dem neuen, mit dem Unibody, das spiegelt wirklich, das spiegelt nochmal zackenstärker als hier dein schwarzes MacBook oder sowas. Das ist, das bin ich mal sehr gespannt drauf.
Ich warte jetzt eh, bis sie neue Batterien drin haben. Lalalala, können wir eine Schutzzelle für den Apple Touch empfehlen? Nö, ich bin noch nicht auf die Idee gekommen, überhaupt eine Schutzhülle da drauf zu machen.
Warum braucht man das?
Naja, wenn man es das erste Mal auf die Straße fallen lässt, dann ist es damit, dass es dank dessen dann überlebt hätte, dann wahrscheinlich schon, aber ich hab es hier auch keine. Hält vielleicht ein bisschen länger, sieht ein bisschen länger neu aus, aber es sieht halt auch ein bisschen länger scheiße aus, wenn man die ganze Zeit über einen hässlichen Schutzhügel drauf hat.
Das stimmt, ich find das auch nicht so schick.
Ich bin nicht so der Typ. Ja, dann wird hier ganz klug gefragt, wird SLC kommen im SDD-Markt oder wird MLC der neue De facto-Standard?
Hey, da wusste ich was, was du nicht wusstest. Ich weiß, dass es sowas gibt.
Ich bin nicht abkürzungsfest in dem Flash-Rahmbereich.
Ja, aber das ist auch exakt alles, was ich weiß. Es gibt zwei verschiedene oder es gibt wahrscheinlich viel mehr Arten von Flash-Speicher, aber welche davon wasbar ist, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht. Aber ich wusste, hey, es sind zwei verschiedene Arten. Und der eine ist besonders schnell und der andere ist günstig.
Naja, dann ist wahrscheinlich der Schnelle auf lange Sicht das, was ich durchsetzen will. Keine Ahnung. Muss man selber mal recherchieren. Hab ich mir noch keine Gedanken darüber gemacht. Wie sind dir die Chancen von Esata als eingebaute Schnittstelle am Mac? Ich denke, diese Chancen sind gering.
Also am Mac Pro ist es nicht so gering, aber an allen anderen Geräten für fast null, würde ich mal sagen.
Beim Mac Pro? Naja, wenn sie das für wichtig erachten würden, dann hätten sie es jetzt schon eingebaut. Genau, ich meine, dann machen sie halt Karte rein. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das kommen wird. Ich glaube, dass sie einfach auf USB 3 gehen werden demnächst und dann gibt es da keine Esata-Diskussionen.
Also Esata, finde ich, gibt es keine Hubs dafür?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube nicht.
Glaub ich auch nicht. Ja, also die ganzen Fragen, die jetzt so in die Richtung gehen, was wir so glauben, was so kommt, gerade was jetzt Macintoshes betrifft, das ist so ein bisschen die Glaskugel, das machen wir hier nur eine Ausnahme. Wir wollen uns lieber über Sachen unterhalten, die es wirklich gibt und die wir selber wollen. Ja, ja, ja. Ach, das ist jetzt hier alles so viel. Gucke mal hier. Je länger der Podcast, desto besser steht hier. Hier ist auch noch mal ZFS, USB 3. Gibt es angeblich einen tollen Artikel in der CT, habe ich noch nicht gelesen. USB 3, denke ich mal, werde ich mal bei Kraus Radio Express feiern. Pamprie haben wir schon gehabt. Tja, iTunes verwalten mit mehreren Rechnern oder nur einer Bibliothek und so weiter. Tja, was gibt es da für eine optimale Lösung? Keine Ahnung. Da hätte ich gerne mal selber ein paar Vorschläge. Das Einzige, was mir derzeit sinnvoll erscheint, es gibt so ein Netzwerk Attached Storage, die weiß ich, ich glaube von HP gibt es jetzt irgendwie so ein neues Teil, was halt tatsächlich auch da AP spricht. Das heißt, wenn du da irgendwie deine Musik drauf denkst, dann hast du das sozusagen als iTunes-Sperre.
Die haben so diesen kleinen Home-Server, der dann auch Time Machine kann, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Werben sie mit, aber habe ich auch nur so kurz...
Machen die etwa AFP?
Die machen glaube ich auch AFP. Wirklich? Also auf jeden Fall haben sie es als Time Machine-tauglich beworben, aber ich habe den Artikel irgendwann kurz offen gehabt und habe seitdem auch nicht mehr gehört.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wenn du ihn direkt dran pappst. Keine Ahnung, das ist... Wir müssen mal ganz vorsichtig sein. Lalalala, Geburtstagsüberraschung, 24.01. haben wir schon gesagt. SSD-Platten-Performance im Alltag. Habt ihr Erfahrungen mit? Ja, das MacBook Air ist langsam.
Kennst du jemand, der ein MacBook Air mit...
Alles dreht sich hier fast um das. Bitte?
Kennst du jemand, der ein MacBook Air mit SSD hat? Also mit 1,5 Zoll, das ist klar, damit ist es langsam. Aber SSD soll ja wirklich... Aber ich habe auch nicht mehr gesehen als die Videos, die ihr auch bestimmt gesehen habt, wo dann irgendwie Photoshop dreimal so schnell startet.
Er ist ja gar nicht mit SSD, was ich jetzt gerade meinte. Nein, kenne ich nicht. Ich habe keine Erfahrung mit SSDs. Ich muss es gestehen. Ich habe bisher noch keinen so rechten Incentive gesehen, diese Ausgabe zu tätigen. Ich meine, wenn die wenigstens mehr Platz hätten oder so, dann wäre das ja schon mal ein Argument. Das kann ich mir allerdings vorstellen, dass das irgendwie kommt. So, hier ist diese Apple-Script-Frage. Er nutzt Apple-Script vor allem als Aktion für Launchbar. Aha, zum Beispiel auch zum Twitter.
Ach so, an dem Twitterscript. Daran wäre ich mal interessiert.
Ja, genau, das sollen wir noch mal schicken. Dann hat hier einer ein Problem mit dem Firefox. Da können wir nicht helfen.
Einstellung lassen.
iPhone Dev Team gibt es jetzt auch auf Twitter. Das steht hier.
Das gibt es schon eine ganze Weile auf Twitter, aber dass hier Muscle Nerd unter dem Namen Muscle Nerd auch auf Twitter zu reiten ist.
Genau, mit großem M und großem N. Da sieht man ihn zwar selber nicht so, aber seine Muscles sieht man. Aktueller Stand bezüglich USB-Platte, Time Machine, tralala, funktioniert das problemlos bei AirPod Extreme und USB-Platte, keine Ahnung. Also Apple unterstützt das ja nicht offiziell. Und also USB-Platte AirPod Extreme angeschlossen als Time Machine. Funktioniert zwar, aber ist ja offiziell nicht supported. Ich vermute immer noch das gleiche, bis zum Beweis des Gegenteils, dass sie einfach bei einer über USB angeschlossenen Platte das Caching bzw. diese Wraiz-Roh-Bestätigung nicht im Griff haben. Und wenn sie sicherstellen wollen, dass ein Backup wirklich konsistent ist, dann müssen sie beim Schreiben auf die Platte, von der Platte eine Rückmeldung bekommen, wo die Platte sagt, ich hab's auch wirklich geschrieben. Und viele Platten machen das halt so, dass sie eben sagen, naja, ich hab's geschrieben, aber was sie meinen ist, ich hab's in meinem Cache und ich schreib's gleich. das ist natürlich über USB nochmal ein anderes Problem. Also ist nur eine Vermutung, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube im Normalfall funktioniert's, aber ich hab trotzdem einfach Ärger. Ich find, dass es einfach immer alles noch nicht richtig gut funktioniert. Aber das ist jetzt wieder diese gleiche Time Machine-Diskussion, die hatten wir jetzt schon. Und ich denke, wir machen einfach beim nächsten Mobile Max nochmal ein richtiges Special mit ZFS und diesem ganzen Kanal. Ja, mit Denis.
Womit ich im Augenblick überhaupt keine Probleme habe, ist eine stinknormale externe USB-Fastplatte. Die ich hin und her mal ranstecke. Geht schnell. Ist alles nicht so schick und so toll, wie ich klapp nur meinen MacBook auf und es macht automatisch Backups im Hintergrund. Ich muss alle...
Klar, wenn man die Disziplin hat, das ist prima. Aber ich merke immer wieder, dass ich diese Disziplin nicht habe.
Es erinnert dir, er macht eine Warnung nach 10 Tagen und dann ist auch oben in diesem Time Machine-Icon ein Ausrufezeichen drin. Ich kriege wirklich nichts auf die Reihe, aber bevor ihr jetzt gar keinen Backup macht, holt euch irgendwie beim La La La Markt um die Ecke für 100 Euro so eine Terabyte-Platte. Schließt die einmal die Woche an, wenn ihr dran denkt oder wenn euch euer Mac Bescheid sagt. Ich habe in letzter Zeit so viele Plattensterben sehen und hören und mitbekommen und die Besitzer sind nie glücklich.
Hier gibt es jetzt übrigens zum Abschluss der Sendung. Wir kommen jetzt ans Ende. Und soll ich dir sagen, wer hat sich gerade gemeldet im Chat?
Wie geht's ihm?
Er hat verpennt.
Aber unsere Anrufe haben sein iPhone so vibrieren lassen, bis es heruntergefallen ist.
Das war nicht Sinn der Sache. Denis, wir wollten das iPhone so vibrieren lassen, dass du davon aufwachst.
Tja.
Ach Mensch.
Denis wird verpflichtet, diese Sendung zu hören. Nächstes Mal ist er dabei.
Denkt euch meine Strafe aus in den Kommentaren.
Genau. Denis hat geschwänzt. Wir machen jetzt hier ein Ende.
Genau. Denis geht's gut, das ist ja schon mal was wert.
Genau, er ist noch am Leben, wir wissen wo er ist. Wir wissen wo du wohnst, Denis.
Also ich nicht, aber Tim.
Okay, dann sagen wir schönartig tschüss. Vielen Dank auch für die Beteiligung im Chat, wie immer. Und generell auch für das Hören von Mobile Max. Wir werden uns auch weiterhin bemühen, alle zwei Wochen bei euch auf dem Kopfhörer zu sein.
Das nächste Mal wieder ein bisschen pünktlicher.
Das nächste Mal hoffentlich etwas pünktlicher, was die Live-Sendung betrifft.
Wir hoffen, dass es etwas zu drittiger.
Wer da noch nicht dran teilgenommen hat, wir geben das in der Regel bei Twitter bekannt, wegen der Kurzfristigkeit. Ihr müsst selber nicht bei Twitter einen Account haben, um davon Kenntnis zu nehmen. Man kann unseren Twitter-Kram da auch per SS abonnieren. Das ist natürlich nicht ganz so fix und so hübsch, aber funktioniert auch. twitter.com/mobile-max. Da kommen dann die entsprechenden Ankündigungen für diese Sendung. Und wenn ihr lustig seid, dann könnt ihr auch unserem Geschwafel auf Twitter zuhören, falls ihr das nicht eh schon macht. Die ganzen Adressen findet ihr auf der mobile-max-Homepage. Ja und mehr müssen wir jetzt nicht sagen, oder?
Okay, dann bis zum nächsten Mal.